Is that your new thing?
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
Well this podcast is already been sponsored.
This shit is just no beginning,
no music,
Brian.
There's nothing.
Didn't need it to be done.
Yeah,
that's it.
Launch.
I'm tweeting sounds right now.
Boom.
So if you heard the news,
what's that?
Uh,
you're just hoping you knew something interesting.
Talk about.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No one's have you,
uh,
whatever.
Dude,
I'm addicted to toilets now.
I've been looking all over these Japanese toilets that we experienced in Japan.
And I,
it's funny because it's,
if you don't know what it is that they're heated already.
And so like when you sit down,
I,
it's uh,
it's like,
it feels like somebody else has sat and sat down and taking a massive ship
before you,
yeah.
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like it's weird and inviting and then you take a shit and then you push a
button.
There's three buttons.
Like one is like hot water,
like me,
like a missile getting shot up your ass hot water.
And it feels really good.
Like I tried to position my asshole
Ms. One of them has big day wasn't the big day is like the blast of water that
cleans your butt and then there's a mild spray and then as a whole
wash it.
See Awesome.
All of them seem pretty good and it seemed one was a little hotter than normal,
but like I didn't want to do the and also headed air dryer.
I don't know if you noticed that but I didn't want to sip,
wait for that.
Yeah that seemed to gay but yet meet trying to like move to have water in my ass
for 20 minutes.
I think I sat there,
I might at one point just trying to,
it felt really good.
It does.
It does feel good.
You never realize how little attention your asshole gets,
especially when it comes to pleasure devices and America.
We have a problem with that.
Like you can get something that massages your neck no problem.
But to have like a warm stream of water that constantly pummels your asshole
would love just sudsy love.
Uh,
for us it like seems gross that you would clean your asshole that way.
And it seems like the more you think about it,
it seems like the Japanese people are clean,
not only for their ass,
whole city seemed clean,
like they seem like really clean,
very clean,
but just the fact that that technology exists.
Yeah.
Everyone should be using it.
Why aren't we using it?
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
Every home should have one of these,
you know,
instead of having a big TV,
you should have something that really,
really cleans your ass.
If it came down to that choice,
either one,
I would say get your ass clean first and save up for a TV.
And it wasn't just like expense or rich people like the,
the bathrooms and all the places we went to head that.
Yeah.
So it's just standard.
It's normal.
Yeah.
Either way they're smart.
They mean they figured out a lot of things.
You know,
they're such incredible innovators.
I love Japan now.
Amazing place.
Fascinating place man.
When it comes to like the way they behave and how the PR,
how polite they are.
So for a lot of people,
like the vibe of it is so like,
uh,
so like more so much more toned down than America and American behavior.
Like for a lot of people it's like,
wow,
this place feels really good.
It's nice to know that everywhere you go,
generally speaking,
most people are very polite,
you know,
it's unusual,
you know?
Yeah.
Even security at the arena.
So polite and so nice
in a one,
one weird thing that somebody said to me,
I want to say who it was,
but he,
he,
he goes to Japan,
I lie.
And he said,
you know,
the sad thing is,
is that if you really wanted to hook up with any girl that you meet here,
all you have to do is tell him like,
like you're friends with like lady Gaga or something like that.
And no one lies.
Like most people don't lie in Japan,
so they're not used to it.
And so they'll believe you.
They automatically believe you.
And like,
and then he said that third leg,
less people lie there.
Yeah.
So statistically Google thing,
that's what he said.
He said,
that's how the,
there they are the,
that they're,
those people are that they're very innocent people and they don't like,
and then they're also very pushed over.
He said like,
like he would order something from the front desk and they're like,
sorry,
you know,
the chef went home and stuff like that goes,
no,
I want this and the rex.
Uh,
okay,
uh,
can,
can you come downstairs and pick it up?
And then he'll be like,
no,
you're bringing it to my room.
And it was really weird.
Like he was saying like how,
how it's kind of sad that,
that they,
uh,
they,
how nice they are and what they did to that food for gum.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
They put it up.
Hi.
Mole's the draw their asshole offer,
but you're fucking food.
Yeah.
Ooh.
But it did seem like that,
it seemed like everywhere you went,
everyone was just insanely nice,
like super innocent and Nice,
very
polite people there.
It was,
it's an interesting culture.
You know,
when you think about what Japan went through for a long time,
when they had like Ronins and when they were the sale essentially it went
through a long period of like civil war.
You know,
they went through a lot of crazy shit.
And the fact that it's the birthplace of martial arts for the most part,
like the,
the early successful martial arts,
the core,
the core components of mixed martial arts.
Uh,
three of them come from Japan.
Yeah.
Judo,
karate and Jujitsu all come from Japan.
I mean,
it's really amazing.
did they fade?
They figured out how the science of launching people through the air with their
bodies and slamming him on the ground.
I mean,
judo for a lot of people don't like,
you've never watched it and they don't have an appreciation for it.
The watching the intricacies of the moves and people like hoist each other
through the fucking air,
slam each other on their back.
It's amazing to watch.
It's a crazy,
I mean they're really technical thing that they figured out how to do like all
the shit they remember.
Like you'd watch like an old,
like a Batman movie where a guy could just flip a due to the air boom.
Well a real judo guy can do that.
They really can grow.
If you're wearing like a winter coat and you get in an argument with a judo guy,
like you're fuck that guy's going to hoist Jude's through the air by your jacket
and slam you in the head.
You know,
it's a,
it's a crazy martial art.
And that emanated from Japan.
They figured that out.
They figured out kicking like,
like all the straight kicks from Japan.
I believe like a karate style kicks,
you know,
the,
the Koreans like revamped a lot of shit and in my opinion made a lot of
techniques better.
They put a little bit more power to it,
but they can't deny that karate is like,
you know,
one of the core tenants of,
of martial arts.
I mean it's a,
it's a good thing to learn.
There's a lot of good techniques and karate came from Japan.
You know,
it's a Ma Jujitsu,
you know,
w what,
what originally,
you know,
became Brazilian Jujitsu,
started off as you know,
Japanese judo and Japanese judo submissions.
It's amazing.
All that shit comes from Japan,
you know?
I mean people have innovated it and then changed it a bit,
but the,
the core idea of it,
trying to figure out how to strangle people on the ground,
all that shit came from Japan.
All those submissions and armbars.
It's amazing how much shit came from there.
Yeah.
And yet that they [inaudible] UFC was kind of interesting seeing people that
were from Japan that were big and pride and stuff like that.
Then fighting Americans and seeing what the outcome was.
It was kind of shocking.
I was,
there was a couple that was one of the most amazing UFC,
so it's an amazing,
yeah,
I think,
yeah.
Yeah.
There was,
there was a lot of guys who got the guy who beat kid Yamamoto.
A is not from a America though.
Oh,
I'm going to,
I'll look up his name because it was important
by the way.
He did,
what's his name?
Yama Mota.
He looked like a video game character his back and his muscles were insane.
That was that.
It looks you're saying live Akiyama Akiyama that's all right.
You raise
no,
but he looks like a video game player.
I was waiting for him to fly.
Start shooting fireballs out of his hands.
Like street fighter.
Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker and he's a bad motherfucker like a musician,
right?
He sells out arenas like for his music and stuff.
Have you heard his music right?
Yeah.
Well I've,
I've watched him sing on a,
on a youtube clip and this is like fucking 30,000 people.
It's nuts.
It's like boy band type shit.
Really?
It's amazing dude.
Is it like that,
that,
that fun Japanese like okay.
Yep.
Von [inaudible] was the gentleman that fought kid Yamamoto.
Von [inaudible] was the,
uh,
he's not from America.
He's,
I believe he's England.
I should probably check that real quick cause I don't want to give some country
credit for this guy.
But he submitted kid Yamamoto Melatonin.
It was,
fuck yeah.
Birmingham,
England.
There you go.
Well,
von Lee.
Yah,
he submitted kid Yamamoto after.
It was a wild ass fucking fight.
Kid Yamamoto clipped him at one point in time and he clipped Kent Yama Motel.
When kitty are clipped him,
he like stayed real calm and composed and kid Yamamoto was like jumping all over
him and the kid kept it together.
And then,
uh,
von Lee,
eventually it went down to the ground and von Lee went form a triangle to an arm
bar submission,
a chain.
It was fucking beautiful man.
The way he hit it was like,
it was so tight and kid Yamato,
first of all,
he's struggling from the triangle struggling from the triangle and the Judaizers
vap just flipped it over and switched it.
Nice.
Really got his hips deep into it and finished that arm bar.
I was like,
wow,
that kid is fucking bad ass.
And I'd seen him fight one other time in the UFC,
but that kid Yamamoto people don't understand what a killer that guy used to be.
He was.
He knocked out,
I think it was cow uno and the boiler Gracie in one night.
He knocked out both of them.
He was,
uh,
in his prime.
He was a beast,
you know,
but I don't know.
Maybe it's the,
I don't know.
Either he has declined to bid or the sport has passed him by.
I don't know what it is but he can't seem to.
But the other guy was what?
Victory 34 and he was 38 or something like that.
Or an age difference.
I think he's only 34 I think kid Yamato's 34 which is still leaves them in his
athletic prime.
Right.
You're like Anderson is a 37 I believe.
And you know Anderson's son,
the fucking absolute,
his prime,
you know.
But it's,
it's also like as you get older,
like the good fighters,
the really technical fighters like Anderson,
like they just get better because they're,
everything is based on technique.
As long as they keep their fitness up and they have good discipline,
which Anderson does,
you know,
like Bernard Hopkins,
the same,
same thing.
They can compete like well,
well,
well into their forties where,
you know,
so Anderson is like in his fucking prime right now in my opinion,
37 years old is not the same as 37 years was just like 10 or 20 years ago.
A guy like him is,
you know,
might take them a little longer to read,
to heal from shit,
but the way he can move and the wake and performance pretty fucking and past
energy and like I could get hurt in the past or something like that.
What's that?
Did he get hurt in the past and I can knock out?
No,
no,
he's never been knocked out.
And he's been a,
he's been stopped in fights by submissions.
He,
um,
tried to say injury back,
couldn't say sir.
He's been tapped a couple of times once when he was younger in his career and
another time,
um,
by Rio,
Shona and,
and one of the most spectacular a submission attacks ever.
He dove on,
I'm like pro wrestling style in a flying scissors.
Hold,
caught him by the legs,
took him to the ground and got him in a heel hook like that.
It was amazing.
I mean it was like one of the most beautiful,
like almost like it looks fake submission attempts ever.
And especially considering he did it on Anderson Silva,
you know,
so Anderson's,
he's a human,
he's just the best,
you know,
he's human,
but he's the best.
So you didn't rewatch the,
that,
no,
I haven't watched him fight.
A lot of people think that a Frankie Edgar,
um,
one at three rounds to two rounds,
when,
when it was over,
I was pretty sure that Henderson had probably gotten a decision.
But man,
it's hard to tell sometimes what other people are seeing.
And uh,
I really believe it.
Sometimes the best view is from the Monitor,
you know,
cause sometimes I'm looking up and you know,
where our heads are basically where the fighters feed our ad,
you know,
and,
um,
we're,
we're looking up and it's,
I mean,
it's the perfect view really.
it's an amazing fucking place to watch a fight,
but to be like super critical about a fight.
I always wonder if maybe the best way to do it would be debt,
you know,
to,
to be able to watch the television screen.
Right.
You know,
I mean it sounds ridiculous because you want to watch it live,
but like there's a cage in your,
you know,
there's posts in your way sometimes.
Like sometimes because of the,
the cage,
I miss shit that's like really critical in a fight.
Like Roy Nelson took this giant swing at Barbary silver dome and virgin got his
back like that.
And I don't know what happened.
I don't know how he went.
I had to go back and watch it in the,
and the replays to see how a resale got his back because while it was happening,
it all took place behind a pole.
So it's like you,
you see it happen and then you got to look down and by the time he looked down,
man,
Fabrizio is such a fucking Ninja.
He had taken that guy's back so quickly.
It was incredible.
And that that's like one of those fights where you see how legit Roy Nelson is
too because Roy Nelson like survived have for resale for doom on his back.
You know,
I also think there should be certain fights where you look at the final outcome
of them,
the person himself and eat.
Like I saw the press conference like afterwards and they,
there was like somebody compared the photos of Henderson and him and like,
you know,
after the fight and just looking at the faces,
you look at look at that and if it's still going on here and like that,
that looks horrible.
I think you know there's is,
here's the thing,
there's a thing called fight metric.
Okay.
And the fight metric is a,
you know,
the idea of there's a bunch of different versions of it.
Kill your fucking cat.
Well yeah,
you kind of going off,
um,
there's a bunch of different versions of it that's not a real cat.
We're talking about an electronic check in case I have canceled
Jesus Christ completely throw me off.
We've even talking about scoring something,
scoring like,
like,
like I hope you were saying something like,
like damn,
it goes like this.
Like if I go like this,
this counts,
right?
This is point,
point,
point.
Think no,
it should be the same.
Again,
strikes,
differences.
One guy,
significant strikes do not equal the amount of damage done by the other guy.
Significant strikes.
So if one guy is a power puncher and he's landing super clean and the other guy
doesn't hit as hard and he's not quite landing as clean or not quite landing as
hard,
the guy who hits your harder is the one is really ultimately winning.
And when you look at like how many punches were landed,
you know,
and how many strikes were landed?
Man,
you know,
I bet Frankie Edgar lender,
a lot of solid strikes,
but he never seemed to like really rock them.
He never,
there was one time when he knocked him down with a right hand,
but Henderson that was at the end of the fight where Henderson want him getting
on top and he was,
he was pounding on him at the end.
Remember.
Right.
So it was like,
you know,
he had done,
I mean,
I think that a Frankie Edgar had done a lot.
It's,
it's conceivable that he,
you know,
easily people watching it at home could have thought that he won.
Um,
just by virtue of the fact that,
you know,
it's an amazing thing,
but he always does.
He gets hurt and he comes back and he can't stop.
The guy's hard.
I mean,
it's really a,
you root for the guy.
That's absolutely for sure.
You know,
Frankie Edgar has the biggest heart of any fighter I've ever seen fight ever.
That guy has zero quit in him and there's a lot of people who would have taken
their check and fucking,
you know,
there's a few shots that he's taken where a of people would've have been like,
and I don't think I can go on,
but that dude always finds a way to go on.
Not just go on,
but he seems to go after you right after you do that to him and he wants to get
you,
you know,
he's unbelievably competitive,
but that other dude did a lot more damage.
That's,
that's for sure.
He,
that Ben Henderson is a really,
really good fighter.
It's not just that Ben Henderson was bigger than him.
It's Benson.
Henderson is really good at almost everything.
His,
his Jujitsu's nasty,
his wrestling's nasty.
He's super strong.
He's always in great condition.
He can fucking kick like Bruce Lee,
that crazy shit he did when Frankie Edwards grabbing his foot and he jumped up
in the air and swung that foot over his head.
That was wild.
I mean,
that's a matrix shit,
you know.
I mean,
the only reason,
what would have happened if that thing landed,
I mean,
Frankie Edgar is sell fast.
It's hard to catch him with anything like that.
I mean he's just,
especially in the early rounds,
that dude moves like,
you know,
he,
he moves like nobody else in the business
I got to sit at have really awesome seats.
Thank you so much.
I mean it was so amazing.
I have to sit right behind Joe.
But one thing I was so amazed by it was that the photographer that UFC
photographer,
he said,
I don't know if he does every single UFC,
but just watching him work like he has like this,
like a camera on both sides.
He's just double like 0.1,
like a gun superfast Josh the shot together.
Look at that shot.
That is just fucking amazing.
He got that perfect.
Eh,
I,
I'm just amazed by his work.
Uh,
just watching him work and everything was that,
that,
that it was so quiet in Japan because everyone's being as polite except there
was some like English people here and there that was like screaming and making
al noises.
And stuff,
but it was awesome hearing the fight sounds.
That's one thing that,
that uh,
I think not many people have probably got to experience,
but hearing it in Japan where it's super quiet and hearing those punches,
that was scary almost.
That was like monster in the woods because it was like you could feel how
horrible that would have felt if that happened to yourself.
Whoa.
Things are always better when people around you shut the fuck up and just enjoy
the things.
But most people when they get to a crowd,
they just want to yell and scream and sometime that's awesome.
Sometimes it didn't.
It enhances a fight when you're around people in everybody's screaming and
something crazy is going on.
Faded enhances me when I'm watching a fight and I'm around a bunch of people
going,
Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
To me that's like,
it makes it crazy.
It makes it so there is something to that.
Would you prefer it to be quiet,
like the Japanese style?
I think that would be my ideal.
Pretty
bad ass.
It is pretty bad ass.
I went to see a that band honey honey last night.
Oh yeah.
How was that?
There were awesome.
Um,
but one of the things that it was,
I mean,
they were really,
they're really,
you're in love with really good.
They're really fucking good man.
So,
um,
one of the things it was weird though was that it was in a crowd where,
uh,
you know,
a bunch of people sitting around drinking and they're watching music and some
people were just having full on like yelling conversations with themselves,
with each other,
you know,
while this band was playing.
And then then some songs,
everyone,
one would shut the fuck up.
And it was amazing.
It was like,
you know,
there was some like really good about,
it's not even that man,
it wasn't that those were the good songs.
It was like you just catch them when they're done talk out.
Right.
Because people just get tired of talking about shit,
but they,
bands don't seem to mind like they seem,
it seems to be okay to talk in certain settings.
I'm sure it's just like practice round,
you know,
that's like there.
They like that kind of where they can kind of play around a little more than
normal.
We're in instead of going like on tour.
They,
I mean did you see them in like a huge set?
Oh No,
no.
It was a really intimate environment.
It was really intimate.
There's probably like their open mind.
Yeah,
well for sure that,
well I don't think it was an open,
I mean everyone was there to see them,
but it was,
it was like some free show that they were doing and they had to do it under an
assumed name.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Kind of funky.
It was like,
I don't think I have some things in El coming off so they can promote it.
You know,
like what does that thing up in Indio,
Coachella.
Oh yeah,
that's what they're on that.
So like I said,
no,
I forgot what it was.
I not,
yes.
Yeah.
They haven't announced it yet.
What are you talking about?
It's online.
Fuck you dare you.
No one who would care anyway,
I just got the scoop.
Why would,
why is it bad to know about something early and Holy Shit,
it got out.
She got out early,
especially in the case of something like that.
Someone put insider trading probably,
but they were,
um,
there were some songs where no one talked at all and you know,
it was fucking incredible.
It's amazing.
Live music is so different than live comedy.
It's so inspirational.
It's so inspirational to go and see something that someone's doing this
completely different than anything that you do,
but it's still performing.
You know?
I really enjoy the shit out of it.
I don't get a chance to do it.
Fuck that.
I don't start taking guitar lessons time.
I have no time.
Certain Guitar and then you don't have to leave your family.
Nobody would Jujitsu.
You want a world where no one I know protect themselves.
Everyone's a big ball of Jello.
Someday it will happen that you will be like,
Brian,
I'm not doing Jujitsu anymore.
We wanted to live with Marissa said setback.
Uh,
why,
why would I stop doing Jujitsu?
Because you're like throw your hip out cause you're 80 or something and be like,
I got to stop this.
Well when that happens I'll definitely stop.
So what would you say I would do?
I know,
what am I supposed to do after that?
I don't remember.
I got too stoned.
Do that.
That fucking weep before you even got here,
he was like well smoke and so we've been smoking and now I'm just,
I'm pretty much gone.
Yeah,
be real with site from Cypress Hill.
Just smoked pot with us.
I want to get him and Doug Benson together and just see like how that podcast
goes.
He seems to handle it really well.
Be Real.
Did I mean he just like,
he never like fades or gets weird or you know he's a,
he's a really nice guy,
man.
Always been a really nice guy.
Just always has a good vibe around them.
Can have sex that he couldn't stay longer cause I wanted to hear like I wanted
to know,
I heard there was some weird stuff with him and Everlast at one point.
Oh really?
Was there.
Oh,
don't go to TMZ and all.
I think they,
I think their friends now.
I think there's just like old long,
I will then don't bring it up.
Let me go find out about it online.
You know,
who knows why you leave something,
you know,
people still send me negative Mencias a shit dice come at,
they sent me a text.
I'll read diocese text.
Yeah.
What,
what happened there?
I'll tell you right now.
No,
he's not mad at me.
Oh,
I love ties.
I dice is one of those guys.
I don't care how,
how crazy you say dices,
you know,
and you know,
I don't care how much people say like,
Oh,
you know,
sometimes he's a jerk.
He won't take pigs.
What lesson?
In my book there's only a few comedy deities.
It's only few of them.
George Carlin's not around,
but die still is.
And it sounds ridiculous,
but when I was a kid,
man,
when,
when dice clay first started blowing up dice clay to me was like,
you know,
I mean,
it's not the most complicated comedy in the world.
The shit was hilarious.
Well,
we were kids.
There's no denying the funny that was in,
you know,
a dice clay album,
you know those,
uh,
those,
those first ones,
I w I listened to them on cassette.
God Damn.
They were good.
They were hilarious.
And who you would like stop your car parked and everyone in the car would be
fucking a howling listening to the cassette.
So this is what he says.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I,
this is the first fucking text ice has ever sent me.
So Cock sucker MNC now stills Titus food specials.
Carlos rules.
Yes.
The pay and trust me,
he will.
By the way,
this is dyce hope.
Good doing good.
That's the tags.
That's awesome to me to get a text like that from dice clay.
That is a fucking honor.
That to me is an honor.
That's awesome.
The first text I ever got from dice club,
that's really cool.
You should print it out.
I love that guy.
When I was a kid,
man,
I fucking thought that was the funniest shit I've ever heard in my life.
And I told you when,
uh,
when we've talked about it with,
um,
uh,
who was on which,
which show wasn't on when we talked about the DYFS thing.
Oh,
uh,
oh,
Amy Schumer.
Schumer.
Yes.
It was right.
Yeah,
for sure.
She's a fan.
Of course.
She was so cool dude.
That was one of my favorite part.
It was amazing.
And Amy Schumer was,
we were talking about the day the laughter died.
Well apparently a lot of people started buying it after we set it.
All right.
I got so many tweets saying how fucking funny is if you're like a real comedy
fan and you want to see a guy go up and do two hours of just fucking around.
I don't have,
I'm not trying to make any money off the day.
The laughter died,
but it's God damn work of art.
But just buy it through doug.com now she's fine.
She's a fine.
Did you uh,
a email inform you when you got back that you would've been making emails from
Japan?
No.
What are you talking about?
Um,
I have some sophistication set up behind my email so that it lets me know if
somebody hacks into my shit.
Try to email somewhere.
I was like,
listen man,
someone's tapped in new shit in Japan.
I was really off the grid in Japan cause I was so scared that like that texts
that you got on your phone that says,
you know,
one megabyte of data is 24 95.
I'm like Oh nope.
No data,
turn off data.
You know,
I didn't want to use my phone at all.
I was scared with text messages.
It's funny how they can do that.
Just charge you a fuck load as if like what you're doing over there as more
expensive.
Yeah.
It's all the same fucking network.
Just process it.
Can you guys just agree that it in the computer,
can you agree that oh well someone comes over and uses our stuff.
What's your rain?
Okay,
we'll accept your rate and you just pay what their normal rate is.
Not this wacky $5 a fucking megabyte bullshit.
Like,
when does that,
where are you coming up with that nobody's paying that much switch to an email
based system where you don't have phone numbers anymore,
you just have emails,
you know like I want to call your email,
whatever.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like,
like when we go overseas it was like zero Zeros or country code eight,
seven.
That's not the issue.
The issue is you need a new service provider everywhere you tap in.
Yeah.
It shouldn't be like the issue.
So you're,
you're saying is that the,
it should be one universal with Skype provider for the whole world and that's
how we talk to each other.
Like an email.
Skype is Skype,
right?
G mail chat.
Even then somebody has to provide the backbone for the Internet,
right?
Yeah.
But it's already done and there's already the internet.
But to be able to,
I mean what you're saying is you want the phone to be like that.
It should be based on Wifi or the Internet should be everywhere and it shouldn't
be cellular signals anymore.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Anymore dry and you're too high.
You know what I think,
I think the government should have wifi towers and the that,
that the whole telephone system and everything like that should be based off
like a government based.
You know like there,
there shouldn't be a t and t,
there shouldn't be a,
you know the cell phone services.
It should just be all,
nevermind.
I don't know what I'm digging myself.
I know what you're saying.
I know what he's saying.
He's saying communication should all be really simple as yeah,
it should.
It shouldn't have country codes.
It shouldn't cost $24 if I'm on one side of this piece of water as the have to
have like local people have to profit from the infrastructure,
you know that that's set up right.
So the people that have created it in Japan or whoever owns wherever you're at,
whoever owns the towers that display or the send out the information that you're
riding on that you're roaming on.
Whoever built that shit and made investments,
I can understand why they would want a service fee.
I can understand like if you want to come over here and use our internet,
you can use it at our rate.
Plus you have to pay $25 you know like a 24 hour users fee.
Yeah,
but it was so ridiculous.
The one megabyte is 24 95 it is.
But I mean if you pay,
if you let people pay at a reasonable rate and then have that same exchange
going on with their company so that if someone knows over in America and you're
from overseas,
you know you can use at and t and it won't be any more ridiculous for you to
yeah,
but it shouldn't be like I accidentally sent you a photo by text message and it
costs $250 and you know,
somebody sent me back one and it costs 125 and I couldn't say stop,
don't want to have imaged automatically downloads that possible that it would
cost that much money though.
24 95 a mega mega megabyte.
A photo is like what,
three megabytes on an iPhone,
something like that.
Like one of those android phones.
And the crazy cameras.
Yeah.
It's something like that.
Have some like eight and 10 mega pixel camera phones.
Don't think.
Yeah,
that's amazing.
That's fucking iPad three March 7th I'm not ready.
I didn't even use the APP.
How to love the iPad one.
I liked the kindle.
You know,
I,
you know,
laptops or a kindle.
You know what I like about the kindle,
man?
I liked the way the paper looks.
I don't like the way it's not glossy.
It looks like paper.
It's like that technology I think is really pretty fucking bad ass.
I don't use the IPAD for any of the ounce.
Maybe watching TV shows.
It's good for that.
It's good for when you're getting tattooed and he watched TV shows where he's
saying that,
Eh,
it helps the time go by and when someone's drilling in your arm,
I think surfing the net on it,
I think it's perfect.
Do you find that there's,
how many websites do you come across to her flash supported that you can act?
Oh,
nowadays everything's iPad.
I never run into switch over old comedians.
I bet a lot of flashlights.
Yeah,
that's a good thing.
My shit was always flash based.
Yeah.
I didn't know the flash was at wonky.
Yeah,
it's always been kind of wonky.
I mean like that's the problem we recover.
That's the problem with websites.
Like,
like we,
I use wordpress for most of my shit nowadays because the reason being is it's
just got to a point where like chrome war would work a certain way with html and
like another browser we're working different way.
So you would make a website for somebody and then,
and then like different operating systems,
like you'd log on the windows and then compare it to Mac.
It's not the same like shit's all fucked up on the Mac version.
So then you have to find out how to fix that.
And there's just too many browsers,
too many operating systems.
There's too many mobile devices that go on the Internet nowadays it seems like
they've almost,
nowadays you just want the most simplest thing like a wordpress or a blogger or
even have it be something else.
Like a tumbler.
You just have your dotcom link to a tumbler nowadays is just to make it easy.
Let somebody else deal with all that fucking cross platform bullshit of design
and stuff.
They ideas just to get your message out to people,
you know,
get your,
so you should [inaudible] dot com go to a tumbler site and that's what I'm
almost thinking nowadays.
Tumbler really that popular.
Is that the Tumblr?
Yeah,
Tumblr.
Tumblr probably could be the next Twitter thing.
Yeah,
you should.
You should definitely get a tumbler.
And nowadays nowadays your tumbler just links to Twitter.
Sorry,
I used to write blog entries.
I should,
if I was going to Redo them,
I should write them on Twitter or I read them on Tumblr or something like that.
Yeah,
that's what I think nowadays it's,
cause I,
I just spent a bunch of money for this,
like a wordpress stuff for desk squad and you know,
it's still,
it's,
it's buggy.
It's fucked up.
Like I tried it and like a different browser and it was a little bit off then I
wanted it.
I'm like,
you know,
this is stupid.
Why if I,
why do I go to like,
you know,
like a,
a live journal.com our Facebook,
it pretty much works exactly the same model.
Like what you're,
are you thinking as long as it was set up somewhere where it's preserved in case
like tumbler gets hit with some crazy virus or some bullshit,
like all your stuff,
they're all backed up so well nowadays.
Yeah.
Cause it's almost like a reliability that is it possible that you could have it
like that where you know you would have your site update,
um,
when you update your site it updates your tumbler as well.
Yeah.
I mean I think you should,
you could store it.
Yeah.
I think like linking it to your Twitter,
linking it to your Facebook,
make it so you just do it one.
But it does separate branch off to all the different things.
What if,
um,
when you go to my site,
there's two options.
One branches you off to the Tumbler,
the other branches,
you're off to podcast.
Now you can do that.
You might not be a good,
a bad idea.
No,
no.
You can do that all you want your website to be as a pretty much a bookmark for
with all your different links.
Like here's your Twitter,
here's your Tumblr,
here's you have it all be like,
I definitely think that I could do something cool with my website.
I know I need to make it easier to find my old writing.
I got to figure out a better,
you know you needed to do to take all that shit and go to a tumbler and re blog
it for you.
You know,
I mean five time consuming is the tumbler,
is it really that sphere?
Is it really that good to do?
Yeah,
but you could cut and paste that into four different things.
You know,
you can cut paste it onto your Facebook page,
you can cut,
put it on your a tumbler,
you can put,
but it's the idea,
the idea that I'm in doing it like that or you do it and do some big public
platform like some my space type thing.
They you're just going to get a lot more eyes on it.
Yeah,
more community,
definitely more community.
And the other option is that keeps you from having to worry about bullshit.
Yeah,
exactly.
Seitzer how seeing it.
Yeah.
Because I have a sites I go to in safari and then I go to them and chrome,
they're totally different.
Yeah.
It's just a pain in the ass to maintain that little frames.
And you have to move the frames around.
A lot of people spend a lot of money on web designers.
They design like an awesome website.
A year later there's a new update and flash,
there's an update and something that throws off the coding a little bit.
So you have to have somebody maintain it all the time.
It's a pain in the ass.
Let somebody else do that now.
I mean,
if it's about getting a blog out,
why,
why not have a community of,
people are like,
you know that smart,
but I just don't trust it.
Someone's going to try to sell iPads from it.
They can already do that.
Somebody got hacked.
Oh my Goldberg got hacked.
Some of the,
uh,
hacked into his shit and was trying to sell something you said hacked or hacked?
His Twitter got hacked.
My aunt got hacked to Mike.
Yeah,
Mike got Hacked twice in a row or something like that on Twitter.
Did he really?
That's funny.
By his daughter.
[inaudible] daughter goes and takes his tweets towel.
Really?
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
People,
man.
I told them,
don't get mad.
They're just Satan.
He'll get down there and fight with them.
You know,
my Kohlberg's doesn't want to take any bullshit from people and he'll get mad.
Maybe he's got a cocktail in them.
You sons of bitches.
Hardy had a lot with Mike Boeck Goldberger over the weekend.
He's a good dude.
That was a good,
he's a very good
dude.
He's a,
you know,
Mike Goldberg spin around sports like his whole fucking life.
He's always been around savages.
You know,
his whole life he's been,
I don't like hockey players and animals.
It's just a fun guy.
Fun Guy to be around.
Yeah.
Japan.
It was a fucking great time,
man.
That was a really interesting culture.
You know what I'm getting sick of,
man.
How come I can't joy something.
We were talking about how Brazil was beautiful and amazing and talking about how
much I enjoy Japan.
I get these fucking emails from people go years,
you look too much.
Why don't you fucking move there?
I would move that,
not email,
excuse me,
Twitter messages.
I've gotten only Twitter messages.
It's so silly.
How can we can't just enjoy certain aspects of another country.
I'm not saying that Japan is better than America.
I definitely enjoy America more than Japan.
There's some things about Japan.
I didn't alike,
but I didn't like the fact that had to cover up my tattoos when I went to
places.
Yeah.
When I went to the gym,
they made me cover up my tattoos.
They actually gave me a shirt to wear.
Why is that?
And sleep shirt?
Because they have a yakuza thing.
Jeff Current,
one of the guys were fights in the UFC,
said he was on Twitter.
He said he was doing squats and a lady came over and started taping up a tattoo
on his leg in the middle of his squatting.
She's like wrapping his,
his tattoo up while he's squatting.
Why?
What was the reason it's covered?
No,
no.
Yakuza gangs type shit.
Oh,
they're worried about organized crime.
They're worried about the perceptions and their culture.
The tattoos have a very different feeling than they do in this culture and the,
you know,
like in their culture,
it's,
if you have like tattoos all over your body like you are,
you know,
it's very possible you're connected to the Yakuza.
That's the initial,
that's originally like the guys who wore the body suits.
Those were like the Japanese gangsters.
There's no tattoo calls or Japan,
right?
Well,
there's definitely tattoo parlors because it's,
and it's not all of them because there's some of them that are,
you know,
obviously there's some of them that are artists and some of them that are just
young people like tattoos.
A lot of Japanese fighters have tattoos.
Kid,
y'all modot has crazy tattoos all over the place.
You know,
it's not,
I mean,
there's people that fight that social restriction,
but you're not allowed to go into a public swimming pools.
If there's a swimming pool at the hotel,
they won't let you get in the water.
If you have tattoos,
you have to leave you.
If you want to go in the gym and you have to wear a long sleeve shirt.
I was just how they are.
I mean,
I guess in their culture just means something different.
It means,
you know,
it's,
it's like people don't want to feel uncomfortable.
They don't want to go somewhere and have someone,
you know,
and I kind of see their point.
You know,
you don't know.
You see someone all tattooed up that's looks kind of creepy.
You know,
you're there with your kids or something.
And what if this person is like a,
an aggressive,
angry person,
you know,
that seems like a weird message to send.
You know,
that's their perception.
I totally understand it.
It's,
they're so fucking nice there.
It doesn't even bother you.
I mean,
even she,
you know,
she's like,
thank you for understanding.
Thank you for understanding.
Wow.
Yeah.
She was very nice about it.
She wasn't judgemental if that had happened like in someplace,
you know,
some,
some fucking weird place,
you know when you like,
you know if you were in like if you had like [inaudible] type place.
Yeah.
If you had like Satan tattooed on your arm.
Right.
You know you went to Kentucky and tried to use Jim's keys,
me weed out with allows Satan to work out in this gym.
So if you want to come in here cause threatened all these people with your site
and Tattoo,
I could see that happening.
It would just kick you out and yell at you.
But this lady was so nice.
I'll study when you have to cover tattoos.
He's I'm okay.
We uh,
we have a short for you or your,
you have a shirt for me,
we will get that shirt for you.
I go,
well I could just go back up to my room and put a shirt on,
put a long sleeve shirt on.
I just don't know what size and I started a large extra large,
whatever you got.
She comes back with a large,
I put it on and to put it on right there for it going,
wow,
I cover up.
That's great.
I'm glad I didn't bust out my waterfall tattoo.
I was like,
what the fuck man,
this is weird.
You know,
it was a really weird huh.
Yeah.
Um,
but that's their culture.
You know,
again,
you know,
it was also weird,
like I went to a couple of the nightclubs,
we and like there when the Russians walked in,
the Russian women,
Russian women were really popular in Japan.
And so these really beautiful like in a runway kind of beautiful way.
Like they're slightly weird looking,
but you can tell that their models,
but they would walk in and immediately this weird energy,
like light,
they were up to something or they just seem to evil.
What's funny,
the Japanese,
the Russians have always had some sort of a connection in Japan with mixed
martial arts because the Japanese,
uh,
always,
you know,
like when they ran pride and they always had like bad ass Russian guys like Igor
of,
of Changsha in came down and of course fade or came down fate or his brother,
you know,
there's a bunch of different guys like Badass dudes that came from Russia.
It's really funny that like connection of Russia and in Japan,
you know,
in,
in mixed martial arts.
So when you're out at a club and then the model world,
the connection between Japan and Russia must be pretty intense as well.
Those girls are everywhere,
right?
It's what they like,
Yeah.
They,
and they seem like,
I asked a lot about them because every time they would walk in there at all,
I would just get the vibe,
the same vibe every time I saw him.
And I guess,
you know,
they,
they get,
they come out feeling like they're going to be the next best thing because they
come out there to actually be lip be logit models.
But then they slowly turn into like hookers and stuff like that.
So,
but allegedly,
allegedly.
But the,
the,
the first batch of them is what you would always see out at the clubs.
And it was just weird because I don't know why I think that I'm just very
intimidated by Russian women kind of freaked me out.
Like they're,
they're very beautiful and they have this weird look or vibe to them that this
is,
some of them are very nice,
don't,
oh yeah,
totally.
Obviously there's some of them that are very nice.
There's a lot of people in Russia that it lived a hard life,
you know?
And,
and people that lived a hard life,
girls,
I've seen some shit that maybe you haven't seen it maybe like their perceptions
of death and life and crimes and what you got to do to get by.
Maybe it's different than yours and maybe they happen to be beautiful as well.
I think it's the beautiful,
they're beautiful and they grew up in a,
in a place,
you know,
who knows?
I mean,
but if a girl's,
you know,
essentially a sex
worker,
most likely,
yeah,
most likely she did grow up in some really fucked up place.
You know,
I mean a lot of these girls that,
that do become like escorts,
you know,
I mean think about that.
Would you imagine if that could,
you know,
imagine if that was your daughter.
Imagine if that was your child that grew to become some,
uh,
some woman who would fly around the world.
And
yeah,
it was also weird was that when you're walking down this one street,
I got lost in Japan a lot by the way.
Cause like you had to do a lot of work are you wanted to work out and stuff.
I would like take weird walks because it felt so safe to walk there at night.
And one time I walked like four hours the wrong direction.
And I had,
I was completely like,
but yeah,
you,
you went fucking nutty one night,
man.
I did.
My thought is always when I come to a place like I better be,
uh,
I would like watching the fights better.
I feel like I'm more focused when I get some fucking sleep,
right.
So I forced myself to get some sleep and you were like,
well I'm in Japan.
I got to make this happen.
And it was weird cause the,
the every three blocks at this one street was just awesome because I think it
was the red light district or something and every three like steps I would take
there would,
somebody grabbed me like he went massage,
massage,
massage.
And so I finally went,
I went with one of them.
I was like,
you know what?
I'm going to try,
I like massages and what she's saying to me converting my head was like $40 or
something like that.
So I was like,
I'll take you up on it cause your sugar,
you're just,
you know,
really hot Asian woman,
woman.
And so like we go up to this weird like room,
it was super weird,
but there's this curtain and then she leaves the room and this older Asian woman
comes out and then I was like,
I got a massage from a really scary Asian women.
Then at the end of this,
the first time that's ever happened,
and then she goes,
ah,
you weren't happy ending.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
That's okay.
And like I had to talk myself out of not getting a happy ending because it was
that,
I mean,
you would think like,
yeah,
why not?
No one's gonna know.
But it was that creepy of an Asian admitted that you would be Dell for a happy
ending under the right circumstances.
I think that's what he just did Sunday.
Got To be more capital works.
And I know I would never say that.
Of course you wouldn't.
Why are you talking about massage on your Dick?
Cause it's not appropriate.
Our society does not condone it or allow it.
Brian,
you can get a massage on your neck.
You can get your nose played with.
That's totally illegal.
You're,
you're right.
I'm just something really gay about that.
Imagine if there was like a guy and that's what he would do.
He's just rubbing kiss your nose.
This does this business.
You know,
some people do neck massage is,
some people are into like reef icology.
What does that reflexology when they play with your feet?
It's not really,
it's not real is it?
Is that real?
I think there's something to it.
When they have like the Meridians of the foot,
is it really?
I think that's real.
Okay.
I don't know.
But I would say cause I mean when they play with certain parts of your face,
you know that that's again,
different pressures of your face.
That's,
you know,
you can feel it.
Especially when it's around the third eye.
You ever feel that when they play with your face?
Yeah.
Where they take hot oil on your third eye right here and then the middle and
they just kind of slowly rub it.
You can feel that the release of some kind of tension in your head.
You know
what?
What the fuck do you think does Brian,
I don't know what you're talking about besides his nice massage or your deck.
Just as nice.
It's really that simple.
You know?
No one wants to look at it that way because you don't want your wife going to
someplace and getting fingered.
It was awesome.
Weird seeing the Africans and in Japan because they would be like the people
that would work.
Did you,
did you know,
I want him to say this before I forget because uh,
what we're talking about going to doctors getting fingered,
you know,
that is what women used to do.
Yes.
The women,
the idea of women being hysterical,
hysterical is connected to like hysterectomy.
It's connected to your fucking losing your fucking mind because you're not
coming.
A lot of women would go to doctors.
It's a long time ago and the doctor would actually manipulate them to orgasm.
Yes.
It was a common thing.
Common thing.
You don't do it anymore.
Nope.
They don't do it anymore.
But man,
who stopped the these oppressed,
you know,
fucked up sexual woman that the,
the thing to do scientifically was to stimulate them to orgasm.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
When did that stop?
I don't know.
I don't know any of the history on it.
I should probably Google it while we're sitting here talking because it's a
really,
I should substantiate it because I'm pretty sure it's true.
Who was the cock blocker on that to some fucking,
probably some religious guy that wanted to fuck man,
you know?
Yeah.
It was weird.
The Africans in Japan where the guys that were like supposed to be the bad ass
kids are going to come up like,
hey man,
come on.
Come in this bar man.
Come on,
you can do it.
Come on.
You want some weed?
And somebody did offer me weed,
which I guess is super crazy illegal in Japan.
So I was like,
no,
as much as I wanted to smoke,
I don't feel like going to jail for a year.
I guess it was like the minimum of getting weed in Japan.
Is it really that much?
Something like that.
He was saying,
I just had a guy we,
sorry.
Yeah,
there's a whole book on this subject.
The technology of orgasm hysteria,
the vibrator and women's sexual satisfaction.
It's a John Hopkins study in the history of technology.
Yeah.
Pretty crazy man.
So listen to this.
Um,
from,
from the time of Hippocrates,
since the 1920s massaging female patients to orgasm was a staple of medical
practice amongst western physicians.
And the treatment of hysteria and ailment once considered both common and
chronic and women doctors low this time consuming procedure for centuries and
uh,
what doctors low this time consuming procedure and for centuries relied on
midwives and later they substituted the efficacy of mechanical devices including
the electric vibrator invented in the 1880s.
And the technology of orgasm,
Ralph mains offers or reading reader's at stimulating surprising and often
humorous account of this hysteria and its treatment throughout the ages.
So this has been like,
that's like a standard treatment for a long time and they just stopped doing it.
What makes sense man?
Just like it makes sense that men need to get jerked off.
Like for women or ideally you would want your husband to do it.
Ideally you'd want your,
you know,
your boyfriend,
your love or whatever you would want that the person that you engage in sex with
to get you off.
But if that's not happening,
you're probably your shit and you,
you know,
you become,
uh,
a less effective functioning Mather method or a member of society rather that
method of relieving the tension than just the physical tension.
If nothing else.
That's all it is,
is there's a physical tension in your body.
You manipulate it.
Ah,
it doesn't mean there's no love involved there.
There's nothing.
It's just you have a buildup,
you know?
It's like blowing your nose except the doctors finger you.
I just,
yeah,
I think the doctor should,
shouldn't do that.
I would hate that doc.
That dr still to your girl.
Yeah.
That's why you're not doing work that like,
no,
I don't want,
I know my wife to talk to her,
wiping my daughters,
but either I want to be able to,
you know,
you want to be able to do your job as a parent.
Your girlfriend be like,
ah,
I'm going to the doctor again.
You want to be able to do your job as a man.
If you'd gone,
if your girls going to the doctor,
get her finger,
bang her a little pussy with a mechanical device because the doctors could have
maybe the doctor's hot.
Maybe he's eating her ass while you listen.
I'm just going to eat your ass.
We do flood.
I can't believe you're doing this.
Is this in the,
you really supposed to be doing this.
I'm just actually pleasing you.
That's what my job is.
Let me ask.
Okay.
Would you be upset if you like,
this is so crazy.
I went to the doctor to get my weekly hysteria release,
you know?
I mean they recommended it.
I have to go,
especially since you can't get it up anymore.
And while in the middle of the hysteria release he just starts eating my ass and
I'm like,
okay,
is this part,
I mean is that cheating?
Is that cheating?
Cheating if he's fingering her?
But if he starts eating her ass,
is that cheating?
He's just being a doctor.
He said I come quicker when he eats my ass and he doesn't have time to just keep
fingering me.
If you were really,
if you were going to finger someone,
the best way to do it is to really just go crazy.
What gets her off?
Is it eating your asshole?
So his body,
his finger and he's probably like,
what's Mrsa?
Mrsa.
Rockhold I don't know how to bring this up.
I'll,
so I'll just be blunt.
Is there a better way to for me to be fingering new here?
If I eat your ass do you think you will come quicker?
Cause my hand's getting tired and there's a lot of people after you in line.
If you ever got print hands from fingering a girl,
I don't think it happens.
I think there's like a,
an alien like slippery slimy stuff that's inside the woman's body and it doesn't
interact with your body like water unless your girls,
unless your girl is pissing on your hands so much that they prune up.
It happens.
That was cause your girl shoots right?
It doesn't.
She have that knowledge.
I just not her blowhole now
could you imagine if that was normal?
If every man and woman and a blow hole and their back and they just shot fucking
water up in the air everywhere we were,
you drink water but you could shoot it up there so that you could do both.
You could like swim in the ocean and you could also like live on the ground.
If we had a blowhole,
why would that hurt us?
An actual little hole.
We could be both.
We could be like aqua man.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
We could swim around.
No problem.
We have a shit design.
You know,
this is one of the theories is that human beings actually evolved the water.
It's called the aquatic ape theory.
The idea is that we're the only animal that has its babies have so much fat on
them.
And then uh,
some of that might have been so that they were more buoyant.
I can case they fell into the water.
You could catch them quicker and like that's like w we were born with this layer
of fat all over and eventually will become like a smaller version of ourselves.
But chimps like as they're born,
the little babies,
a little muscle bound little babies,
they're not all fat chubby like our babies.
Our babies are all fat and Chubby.
What have like thousands and thousands,
thousands of years ago before caveman,
before everything,
we were just like really,
really fat and just lived in puddles.
And so it'd be just like we'd still talked the,
hey,
what's going on?
But we just like lay in the huddles and we couldn't move cause we couldn't
walk yet.
Well maybe we found some food that was so awesome that goes in the puddles.
That was all we needed to do.
You know,
it just tasted like chocolate cake and it was the best thing for your body.
And so it's like the best way to get at it.
Just eat it all day and just,
we just laid in puddles and eight fungus.
There's chocolate cake,
fungus to tasted awesome.
What a creepy visual.
Yeah.
What could we visual Floyd visual,
you know,
it really creeped me out the other day,
man,
I was watching something on volcanoes and uh,
you know,
they were showing all the different towns.
Apparently they have discovered a whole volcanic um,
uh,
like a,
an entire forest.
I believe it's in China under a,
under a volcano,
like hundreds of millions of years old and they're going to like dig down into
this and this and like a whole,
like forest had been covered by volcanic ash and shit.
They look at their sort of just discovering it and I'm piecing it now and you
realize when you see shit like that that at any point in time these Jeez giant
natural disasters that have happened so many times over the history of the
planet.
Like we haven't got that wired yet.
We don't know when they're coming.
We don't know what,
what to do when they hit or if we can do anything.
Like the big ones,
like the super volcanoes and the shifting of the polar ice caps,
like all that stuff's coming.
Like that's how the planet works.
Like it almost seems like it's designed that way.
Like there's a little reset button,
it goes on to Yale and play the game for so long and then pat time's up.
Next civilization,
you know,
you've got to bring in the next people that play the game.
You know?
I mean it almost really say,
could you imagine?
I mean,
if that's what civilization is,
I mean we really realistically humans in this form.
How long have you been around?
How long a monkey's been around it?
How many millions of years?
Let's just get crazy and just say 65 million years ago when the dinosaurs got
hit by that big meteor,
let's say there was no monkeys back then because I'm pretty sure there weren't
so just in 65 million years,
which is nothing.
All this shit has happened.
You know,
all this shit has happened.
Who knows?
This couldn't have happened.
What if this happened already?
What if the whole thing had been started from the beginning to the end?
People had to figure things out.
There was,
you know,
an advanced civilization and it got hit by a fucking media and then it had to
start all over again from scratch,
from scratch with Amoebas and things that survived with the bottom of the sea to
eventually,
intelligently.
How many times could that happen in the course of a son?
You know,
all that shit's possible week.
This could end for us at any moment,
any moment,
boom,
the sky turns and that's the end.
Cause a hyper Nova,
a couple million light years away blew up on us.
God Damn,
I'm scared.
I was.
I was kinda scared of flying back.
I started if I kept on falling asleep and then waking up thinking about could we
are flying over the ocean and was the first time I ever flew or the ocean and
that really,
if you think about it while you're flying over the ocean,
it's really creepy to think about like when you were sober too.
Yeah.
You were actually a little drunk stove.
I was definitely not.
And you're not really.
Yeah,
I know when you're hammered,
but,
but it was like I was thinking like if there was an emergency landing,
you needed to get these
and then I was thinking about like how you going to give you get you by the way.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
If something goes down in the middle of the middle of the ocean,
they don't send in a plane to land and we'll get it.
Okay.
They have to bring in boats.
Fishermen get the sharks.
That body out of some boat.
Yeah,
somewhere near you where it happened.
They send that out.
Fuck that.
Fuck that and dude,
but we're going to do it again.
Stay home.
I don't know.
Japan.
Don't think of it when you're flying in the ocean that I kept on thinking about
it.
I couldn't stop thinking about it was freaking me out.
Yeah.
Our forms of transportation are quite frightening when you think about what
happens when they go wrong.
But what's really fascinating is what does the future hold?
You know,
200 years ago when people were first putting together railroads,
they would've never,
ever believed that we could get to the point we are today.
The 200 years ago,
before there was no cars 200 years ago,
right?
In 1811 there was no cars.
So imagine that.
Imagine that amount of time and imagine what has taken place and now think about
what that amount of time in the future is gonna hold.
We're gonna admit it's going to be like people miss.
If you don't get there,
you just splatter into fucking billion particles and blow off in the wind.
That's what's going to happen.
We're going to make like some sort of a star track replica thing where you beam
yourself places and Shit's going to go wrong sometimes.
So there's going to be like terrorist.
It's that set up mirrors so that as you tried to beat herself up at fucking
scatters your app,
your essence all throughout the universe.
You know,
who knows,
who knows what kind of crazy time travel teleportation shit that's going to,
they're going to be able to figure out.
As far as like travel,
I think it's going to 200 years.
I think it's going to have something to do with traveling back from Japan to La
back and forth so many times until you start going back in time.
More and more and more.
How weird is that though?
Like we relive this same morning twice.
Pretty
crazy,
but do you think that at a certain point in time when you know,
if they've,
I know they've done things with particles where they've managed to teleport
particles,
but I don't quite understand that shit.
I don't understand if they're,
I don't know what's really going on there,
but you got to assume that if they could figure out a way to transport anything,
anything,
even an email,
even the idea that something's going through a fucking going through a wifi
network in space,
it's in the air and it lands in your fucking laptop and you're just sitting
there wirelessly connected to the universe and then something comes in a big
file,
a big piece of information.
And now the fact that you can do that,
you start thinking about what if you could figure out a way to break a person
down to ones and Zeros.
You know what?
If you could break a person down to a program,
if you commit to being a program in our intranet,
we offer you a lifelong creative adventure.
You can decide what you want to do with your life.
You'll be living online and your consciousness will be in the hand of trusted
engineers that were responsible for such amazing movies as Lord of the rings and
King Kong.
And you could just have you get to sign up for this shit.
And as long as your credit holds out,
they just connect you and your essence to a computer and they throw you into a
computer simulation and you're just a plug in the wall.
You already like the Matrix.
Is it possible?
We already are.
What is that guy's name?
The Guy who decided he was going to give up Joe Biden?
No,
no,
no.
In the Matrix.
He was a very famous,
like he was always in those gangster movies.
Joey pants,
Joe Pantalone,
you know,
you know what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
Very good actor.
Anyway,
he was,
he's the one who was in the Matrix and he decided that he was going to give up
and he was going to join the other side.
He was like one of the good guys,
one of the parts of the resistance,
but he couldn't,
he couldn't hack it anymore.
Right.
He's getting tired of it.
So he's going to give up Morpheus and he was getting,
and they were like in a restaurant with him and he's eating steak and he was
like telling him that he wants to be like a good looking guy.
Like an important person.
Maybe a movie star.
Oh right,
right,
right.
You remember that?
Yeah.
That was pretty wild.
Cause you know there'd be people like that if that really,
if that became really presented itself,
like here's what you can do.
You can either continue what you're doing or be the baddest motherfucker in the
world in the Matrix and you won't be able to discern whether it's really not.
A lot of people would take that.
Yeah.
What a what a weird choice and a real possibility.
You know when you stop and think about what an incredible movie that was,
that that movie presented,
this idea,
you know,
and the,
the,
the fact that as technology moves forward,
that might one day become a possibility.
Some sort of a computer neuro interface that projects a created reality into
your own head and hijacks all your senses and has all your senses feeling and
smelling and it has your Dick at and hard and you really think you're fucking,
you think everything's going on.
You're the king of the God damn world.
You're Conan the barbarian,
you're slaying dragons.
You never even die.
Every time you want to win,
you win and you just fucking bitches everywhere over the bodies of your enemies.
It probably is going to be something like that.
We're going to wake up from the program.
I didn't go,
Oh yeah,
we started this program a long time ago,
you know,
that were somewhere else and we're like,
oh,
we forgot it.
Oh,
we're just in a buggy version.
Yeah,
you don't like it.
Like when you wake up from like getting anesthesia or something like that and
you're like,
wait,
what the fuck?
Oh yeah.
I had the operation I,
I was knocked out.
But what if we wake up from life like that where we were like,
Oh,
I started this program
is life program hack on my phone.
Somebody just knocked on the door.
Yeah,
that was car accident.
Oh.
Um,
this is what I was going to talk about,
the very beginning of the podcast.
What I went,
oh,
let's get some time in before to talk about this.
There's a,
a a fighter apparently that's on this season of the ultimate fighter that uh,
allegedly they're saying was in a gay porn.
Why?
Yeah.
I allowed to talk about this.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's real.
Um,
hold on fighter on all to,
I wouldn't even say his name because I don't know if it is real.
That's pretty cool.
Yeah.
But what I will say is,
MMM,
I'll say two things.
One,
the WHO gives a shit?
Jesus Christ is always that way.
But anyway,
right.
You know,
I mean the dude's gay and he just sticks to what it is,
is,
is training and fighting.
There is something different.
We were rolling around with some guy.
That's only if he's fuck no,
because I've rode with women and it's never been sexual in any way,
shape or form.
Not Porn Stars.
We rolled with porn stars.
No.
But I rolled with,
I've rolled with pretty girls before.
It's been a few times.
And you know what man?
First of all,
you gotta be careful cause if they're good,
like you rolled it out like corn,
it's pretty shitty.
Or someone like that or Ronda Rousey,
like I'll fucking strangle you.
Like a dude will too.
But you got to watch your ps and qs.
But it's never,
you know,
it's never that.
It's always,
it's always rolling.
You know,
anybody who's rolling is rolling.
Nobody's rolling,
grinding their Dick on,
you know,
if they are,
they getting choked out.
It just doesn't last.
You just don't want to think that.
Yeah,
you don't,
don't you don't.
But I know I've rolled with gay guys.
Absolutely.
100% for sure.
There's more than one of rolled with more than one gay guy guys who were openly
gay.
I've rolled with guys who I,
I'm pretty sure were gay.
You know,
it's not,
it's just who gives a fuck if you're wrong,
was the person is not as long as the person is not inappropriate with you or
they don't.
They don't do Sean you.
But same way with men and women together,
man.
Can you imagine if men and women shared one fucking locker room everywhere in
life,
you know,
and women just have deals,
guys,
Douche anonym have you ever rode with somebody and their boners really hard and
he fell it,
the hall
just push back on it just to set up a submission,
you know?
Well you've got to distract him with your bud hall.
Just Rub.
You could feel the tip of the cock.
You have to develop a feeling for the tip of the cock.
You got to know how far you can push it before he's actually raping you
feel it on your back.
No.
And you're like,
ah,
that's definitely you gotta think man,
if you're a gay guy and you were,
you know,
really into like fighting for your pussy.
If you wanted to fight for your boy pussy,
you know you want to go do battle and then fucker guy take them down,
mount them tickets back and then just get in that extra hook.
Some dudes,
that's what they're looking for as long.
Listen,
as long as any guy doesn't do that,
as long as you don't go rape and other guys you're training with,
you know,
but was getting is the thing that why I wonder,
I don't know if the guy actually did this as we,
which is why I'm not saying anything,
but I would wonder if he was honest about it.
If I get anybody who asked,
I would do.
I would assume that that's like a part of a contract,
right?
Yeah.
Like there's certain stuff that we don't want you to have done.
You never need to say it.
At least.
At least you think.
Yeah,
I do because I would not want to roll with somebody that used to do gay porn.
That's my personal choice.
Okay.
If you wrote with a guy who,
because it had,
because when you're rolling,
who was gay who had gay sex.
Is that okay?
I don't know.
No,
I don't think so.
Really.
I just,
cause I think when you're,
that's the last,
I don't,
I don't think it's the last frontier that's the last frontier.
You're assholes.
The last of the Mohicans,
right?
I think it's the same way.
It's like when you,
when you get pulled over from a girl cop,
you get a,
or a guy cop and your girl and you need to be pat down.
You think they have to get a girl cop.
Same reason.
I don't want fucking to be wrong.
Your Dick Armey if you like.
It's
different because in that situation you have to be subservient.
And that situation where a cop is there that like you have to stand still while
the cop essentially molest shoe.
But that's why people have a hard time with that.
I don't know though,
but it's really interesting because,
um,
you know,
I mean,
do demand have that same option.
Like if a woman like no men don't have like a a woman,
can't pat a man down.
Is that true?
I don't think they can write a man has to pat a man down.
Correct.
So what you can't like be humiliated by a woman either,
right?
I think,
think yeah,
unless you as men,
I don't think men can pat women down,
but I do know that there was one crazy video online where a woman got arrested
for something,
turned out to be totally innocent by the way.
And these cops were giving her a strip search and she's fucking screaming,
they're holding it and she really did nothing.
And it's the craziest video to watch.
The cops just fucked up and went way too far with it.
But they held this girl down and like strip searched her and it turned out she
did nothing,
man.
It was just all fucked up.
It was just,
just,
they just told her to do it.
She wouldn't.
And then it got out of hand and then you know,
when people think that they're,
they're being disrespected or their,
their authorities not being,
you know,
re accurately represented,
they'll,
they'll step in and take things to a horrible place.
And that's what I think probably happen.
But it's a,
it's a terrible thing to watch because he watched the tape.
That could be my sister,
you know,
that could be my,
my mom,
that could be my wife that could,
you know,
and these,
these guys are holding her down for her that she's not a fucking terrorist.
Like what are you doing man?
Why are you holding her down and strip search her?
Look,
this is what you do.
Just push her in a room and ask her some questions for a few minutes before you
fucking check inside her asshole for bombs,
you know,
how about you do that?
And then you would find out,
oh this is a big mistake.
Someone's fucked up.
Okay.
You're not a danger to society,
man.
It was just someone that can drive you home.
Sorry,
we didn't have to look inside your butthole at all.
So there was just a big mistake.
I mean,
that's what they do.
Do they do,
did they check your naked body for a woman that's so humiliating to be in a room
with men,
they're holding you down there checking your naked body.
I mean,
essentially that's like a rape,
a power move.
I mean,
it really is.
You know,
that's not a dangerous woman.
She's not shooting anybody.
She's not trying to blow up the fucking world.
She's just some lady and mood,
whether she's drunk or crazy or what.
You don't have to be stripping her down like that.
That's nuts.
But you give people the option,
give,
give people the ability to do that.
People get out of hand.
That's why tasers are fucked up.
Tasers are great.
If every cop was awesome,
but every cop's not awesome.
So the idea that you just randomly giving tasers,
so all these dudes and some of them,
I've seen some of the moves where people,
Taser people,
I've seen some of the shit that happens and it's fucking wrong man.
And it's a salt and it's a crime and they should take the fucking tasers away
from those guys and they should lose their jobs.
Yeah,
but what if it's like Taser versus gun,
where in most instances people probably got shot by a gun?
Was it a,
if a is in any sort of a situation where a guy is threatening to him,
then the guy should get tased?
Absolutely.
If they're in any situation where it looks like the guy is trying to physically
harm them and they can taste that guy,
fuck yeah,
that's not what I'm talking about,
man.
I'm talking about people that have bad days.
It just Taser people.
But you don't use a lot of that Carly taken off.
No,
no.
It's a good weapon for honest cops.
But the problem is there's too many people that use it just cause they get
pissed off or they want immediate respect.
You know this guys that get out of control with any kind of fucking any piece of
power,
anything,
whether they're your landlord or your boss or a cop or anything,
there's certain dudes that just cannot handle where they get to be the guy in
control.
They can't handle it.
They go on ego trips are not satisfied enough with their own life.
Well most of them can.
You know,
you just got to figure out a way to weed out the shithead cops and then tasered
would be awesome while I'm looking at photos of that guy that you're talking
about,
the gay guy cause he got him fucking guys.
Whoa.
Let it all be a big Photoshop.
Could be a big Photoshop scandal for sure.
Now that's crazy.
I say who cares man,
it gives you extra motivation and not let that guy beat your ass.
That's what I say.
I say good for him man.
But you know,
don't ever talk shit on and wonder,
you know what's going to happen as far as like sponsors and shit liquid.
If that guy's a,
that would be interesting to see if like a sponsors got homophobic and didn't
want a sponsor when he was having fights,
you know,
that would be kind of interesting.
You know,
they've never had that in the female side either.
Heather,
they ever had a female porn star.
It turned out that she was like a lesbian porn star and she was fucking bitches
up.
Have you ever had that?
I don't think so.
What's that one d girl with a penis?
Uh,
China.
Did she do that?
She didn't do MMA now,
but she did WWF.
It didn't share,
but then she did porn afterwards.
Oh,
I thought it was,
I never mind.
You're right.
Yeah,
she's doing support.
And so if you feel like beaten off to that,
go right ahead.
You can go crazy.
You can go get that.
I think it was,
um,
like a,
like,
like a high end movie too,
right?
Like I'll live it or something like that,
Probably.
Yeah.
Some along those lines.
I think deep inside China or some shit,
you know,
it's always some silly name Tepe in China.
Yeah.
But she never,
she never had an MMA fights.
I don't know.
I don't think she was a lesbian either.
Panda X,
x xpress.
Yeah,
she became a porn star after her success as a wrestler.
It's fucking hard businessman getting thrown around like that.
There's probably very few jobs out there.
The tax your body like a pro wrestler.
He wants those dudes fucking slamming chairs.
You knew each other and shit like holy fuck,
that does not look fun.
That looks like that's fucking nutty man.
Yeah brother.
All those dudes have like fake hips now and fucking disk repaired discs and you
know like,
like whole Hogan,
that poor guy.
He's had a whole bunch of surgeries.
He's just,
just the size of him.
You would think it would be difficult to live life like the weight and just
walking around with all that.
He's enormous.
Like people don't realize how big Hulk Hogan is.
That's a fucking giant man.
I met him the first time I ever met him.
Dude,
he had cowboy boots on.
He was out in front of the cigar.
There's like a Havana room in Beverly hills and I guess he was into cigars and I
pass by him on the street and dude,
he's a fucking mountain of a man.
Just carrying all that weight around.
It's got to be brutal.
And your in your back and your,
your knees,
not,
nevermind,
let people throw in you through the fucking air.
No,
thank you.
Huge in Japan by the way.
Pro Wrestling's enormous.
Yeah.
Ariel Helwani was going to hang out with us one night but before he went out he
wanted to go and check out some uh,
some uh,
pro wrestling thing.
And by the time he came out I was already asleep,
but it was the local pro wrestling.
They're like really into this leg,
like crazy,
wild pro wrestling style.
And they have American MMA fighters come over and do matches like they had Tim
Sylvia had a match with Jerome Le Banner.
They have a pro wrestling match and it's almost like they're really fighting
choreographed fights but they have to eat shots like drum the banner like kicked
him Sylvia and the stomach.
Like it's like real shit,
man.
They're really hitting each other to,
not full blast but enough.
So you're like,
Holy Shit,
this is like,
this is hard stuff.
And they use like real submission holds,
you know,
it's pretty wild.
Like a lot of the guys that do like pro wrestling also fight.
It's kind of crazy.
Like that's where I guess soccer,
who's one of the most famous Japanese mixed martial artists ever.
He actually has a roots.
His roots are in pro wrestling,
you know,
just,
but he could really fight,
you know,
so he would do all that,
choreograph shit.
But he could do it to you if you want it to as well.
You know,
you think rampage is done?
No think I have a knee injury.
Apparently.
Apparently his doctor had told him not to fight.
Look,
you know,
people want to poo poo this and you,
you don't know,
you know,
people would say,
oh,
you just push it out.
He puts you down and look like you just want to get a paycheck.
I heard a lot of different things like that and I disagree entirely.
I think he,
uh,
he was in a situation where he wanted to put on a great show.
I know that it was like super important for him to fight in Japan.
So if he fought,
regardless of the fact that he hurt his knee like that,
you know,
and you look at how he made it,
all the pieces point to that he was 211 pounds at weigh in.
So that means something was wrong that he couldn't train something was wrong and
that's why he couldn't cut the weight because you need to do it when you're
cutting a lot of weight,
like rampage,
she's going down from like two 30 sometimes.
And when you're doing that,
you got to do that over a period of time where you're really smart about your
calorie intake and you're really smart about the amount of cardio you do and
you,
you know,
you got to,
there's a lot of getting in shape.
There's,
that's a big part of that.
You know,
sometimes guys,
when they come in heavy,
the camp becomes more about losing the weight than it does about improving
skills.
And that's why I like guys like Anthony Johnson,
they,
they'll do better actually.
And they look better when they go up a weight class,
you know,
uh,
my opinion because then all of a sudden they're not cutting nearly as much and
now they get to focus their entire training camp on actual skills.
But that said,
you know,
it's,
it's um,
you know,
it's saying it's,
it's an open debate.
You know,
there's different people know how to do it better than other people do it.
So,
you know,
the,
the I,
the idea of one person having it figured out universally for every person who
competes,
that's never gonna happen,
you know?
Yeah.
It's wild.
Watching fights in Japan though,
isn't it?
I loved it when you to go back there,
I really like,
I'm thinking about like going back,
just,
uh,
well there's so much right
where we were at,
like with the fights took place at the site,
Thomas Subaru arena.
There's so much history there,
man.
That place was like the place for all these fucking huge pride events,
Just like the biggest,
most historic ones ever.
Like most of them went down there.
There were some amazing fight it took place there.
Like if you're like,
uh,
martial arts historian,
like I'm,
I'm not,
I'm a geek,
you know,
martial arts geek.
But you know,
like going back and looking at old prides and shit,
when Nogueira was on top,
I still watch those.
To this day I still would like,
to me that's like,
you know,
that they're like movies that like our welcome old movies to watch.
Like it's a work of art.
Then I'm looking at,
you know,
and I watch like some of the old pride fights,
they were fucking awesome.
That was so fun.
Okay.
You know,
sort of be there and that place where all those fights went down.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is a part of like,
to me like one of the,
my favorite things to,
to watch and be a part of mixed martial arts.
This is like,
okay,
a historical event to me,
you know,
this is like holy shit,
like word in the site,
Tama,
Super Rena in Japan where it all went down,
you know.
So it was,
it was,
it had a definitely an extra charge because of that.
Should we call her?
That arena actually expands it.
You can make it bigger or smaller or comes up to rise.
The uh,
the sides expand.
Yeah.
It's like super fucking high tech man.
It was also weird seeing all the animation like I had said like,
look,
keep your eye out for the animation or is animation everywhere.
I know he's like everywhere,
everywhere.
Everywhere you looked there was the little cartoons.
Yeah.
Well you should say cartoons on animation.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Motion.
But everywhere where people have businesses,
they have like a cartoon pickle.
Yeah.
You know,
that runs their business or a kitty cat or cats or cats.
Bears like teddy bears like that run you in,
you know your,
your,
your company is represented by a big smiley teddy bear.
Yeah.
And even like the description on the toilet,
like you know shit like a kid like reaching in there and there'd be like this
cartoon of the character crying and stuff with the cartoon and telling you not
to like stick your mouth on the toilet seat where the water comes out.
They don't want anybody hovering their head over and just drinking this shit
water.
Oh God.
Yeah,
because who knows?
I mean if you take a giant dump on the jets,
just some monster dump,
you know,
maybe some of that shit's still sticks to the little little hose.
It doesn't quite got it all off.
And then your kids in their Jenkin and out of it like a fountain and they get
some horrible disease is awesome having your poop in their mouth.
It's also weird seeing it that that Starbucks cups,
like everything was smaller in Japan,
like the Venti iced coffee in America,
you know,
he's like,
I don't know,
it's like a size 20 ounces or 20 ounces.
Yeah,
they're,
the Vinci was a small,
what we have as a small event,
he coffee is just fucking crank.
You might as well just go take crank.
You get a Venti Starbucks.
Somebody might as well just give you a line.
I don't even,
I get Trenta.
I could turn to add shots every day.
Every single day.
So Trent is 30 ounces of ice coffee and with shot two shots.
Usually every day you're like numb to caffeine.
Huh?
I just did that once and that wastes me right the fuck up.
That groggy part in the morning.
I want to be awake.
I wouldn't be able to drink a beverage and be like,
alright,
you know what you should do just out man.
Perform a series of exercises,
forced yourself to do chin ups,
push ups and body weight squats every morning you'll wake right the fuck up in
Jujitsu with a gay guy.
You don't have to
Chesney,
you just do a little bit at 30 minutes.
Gj Etsy with a gay guy or make sure you keep your base,
make sure you don't want to take you back.
I kept on thinking,
oh wait,
we already talked about this and now what?
Never mind.
We'll deal.
Tell me now.
I want to say it now.
It was really cool having that dude from house of pain and they're,
my friends growing up were just huge house of Payne fans.
That's all.
They listened to it nonstop and smoked weed.
Like he's very connected with the,
the weed.
Uh,
uh,
what do you think?
Are you talking about?
I'm sorry.
I meant Berio.
Oh,
did I say a pain?
you meant Cypress.
Cypress Hill.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
you silly fucked are not the same.
I know.
I get them confused and racist.
I get them.
Why do you get them confused?
I don't know.
They just,
same timeline when they can kind of came at the same time.
The kind of had that,
they used to have the kind of the same sounds,
you know,
like I used to mix them up a lot.
I've done that before with Blake,
one 82 and someone else,
I forget who the other bands,
like
green day,
they're all together.
To me,
just the names.
I don't know what it it was.
Obviously,
I know they've totally different music,
but the names every now and then for whatever reason,
you have a a misfire and your brain,
you've connected someone with the wrong person for like a couple of months and
then you have to relearn it and when you relearn it,
sometimes it doesn't take like,
what about Ho?
Okay.
Oh yeah,
that's the,
that's the other band.
That's the other band.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
What's the other band?
That band that used to sing out?
Take me past the breakers.
Watch through.
Oh yeah,
we can.
Oh Man,
I'm fucking dying over here.
They were great.
That was a song.
Santa Monica Everclear
on it.
Everything.
I got him mixed up with Everlast alive.
Oh yeah.
Well I can see how that would happen.
That guy had some bad ass fucking music though.
I love that guy.
Where's that guy?
And I know he bleached his hair a lot though.
I wonder if he's still bleaches.
It probably overdosed on Pussy.
That song was too good for a man like that.
She's out there with that fucking awesome song in the world.
You know,
out of nowhere,
boom,
a tsunami of hot pussy comes at you because if you're wonderful music probably
couldn't handle it.
Who could blame the Fella?
That's what I always assume when anything happens in a dude gets off track.
You know like someone who you really used to enjoy it and they get off track.
You always feel like it's some Jen Michael Vincent tsunami of Pussy.
I just threw them off track.
Partied way too hard,
go way too fucked up.
You know,
that's the argument that the people that are in counseling and in rehabilitation
for alcohol and drugs,
that's the argument that these people will always use.
So people that fall apart is the people that take whatever and just blow their
fucking heads out.
What they're missing is how many people are making life so much more
interesting.
Can you imagine how much less interesting life would be if you were sober all
the time?
Do you not understand?
Like,
it's just some people that have never had a drunk fuck with their ex girlfriend
or you're like 23 years old and you text her in the middle of the night and she
responds and you're like,
what are you doing?
You dirty bitch.
And she responds back,
I'm waiting for you to come over here and fuck me.
And you're like,
oh shit,
it's on.
And you go there and you're like,
you know,
you probably been broken up for a long time.
You never expected a fuck her.
And on top of it,
she's just as drunk as you.
I need this.
And this doesn't mean anything.
No,
it's telling me nothing.
It's not mean we're getting back together.
Nope,
nope,
we're just doing this right and boom,
you don't do that without being drunk.
That's one of the most beautiful moments in life.
And you don't even get there without being drunk.
Cause if you're not drunk and you go this and she's just not for what I'm
looking for right now.
And even though my emotions are telling me to go visit her,
my rational mind is saying,
this is just,
this is not a smart move.
I got to just move on.
I've got to be positive.
I'm got to get my shit done.
You have a couple shots of Jack Daniels.
You start fucking thinking crazy.
You have a Tequila.
You want to do one more with Tequila.
I'm not scared.
And that Fourth Tequila hits.
Boom.
Let me just text this pitch real quick.
Do you have any,
people would not have that moment if it wasn't for alcohol.
So how could you say?
Just because a few people die.
The rest of us shouldn't live awesome.
Alives
flavored by alcohol.
You know a lot of the fun shit that happens,
it's flavored by alcohol.
People need to accept it.
It's a great drug.
It's not the best.
No it's not.
But it's good for a lot of shit and it makes things fun sometimes.
It definitely opens up doors that you normally wouldn't open because here,
whatever reason,
that's why you're dancing.
I'm fabbing a fucking great time too,
by the way.
Dancing,
having a great time,
you know,
laughing your ass off high five and your friends,
hammered.
It's not bad.
You gotta be careful of your health.
Okay?
You've got to drink a lot of water.
You've got gotta.
Make sure you don't do it too often.
You don't want to jolt your system.
You want to give yourself plenty of time to recover.
Take your vitamins.
But every now and then,
don't be a pussy.
Have a drink.
Come on man.
Just a little shoddy pool here or there.
One of the things I always respected about Anthony Bordain quit heroin to equip
booze.
I blacked out in Japan every night.
I was there.
I think I fucking,
I went super deep.
I got disciplined son.
I know how to use it.
I know when it's time for me to get drunk.
I was doing the robot and then packed night club in your hand just because I
knew no one would say shit to me.
I,
uh,
my,
my time was so,
I was so fucked up.
Like we just got in for folks who don't realize we've got an yesterday.
We're the only last time.
I didn't feel it going there,
but I feel it coming back.
Like I was talking yesterday.
I just couldn't.
I woke up today at 7:00 AM.
Yeah,
it's completely confusing.
Your brain is like,
what is going down here?
It takes,
you know what's helped,
what helps Melatonin.
Melatonin is great for resetting you.
It's a,
it's a natural thing.
It's natural but don't go to Dubai with it cause you being arrested sleeping's
thing.
Yeah,
both.
It's a natural supplement.
I don't know how they make it.
I say it.
I'm saying it's a natural supplements.
If I fucking looked into it deeply,
but quite honestly I've just used it as green tea extract,
but that has caffeine in it.
Brian White series for relaxation.
Do you really for sleeping but okay.
You relaxed with caffeine.
You just drink so much caffeine.
The caffeine that's in green tea like can't fuck with the shit that you get from
a 30 ounce Starbucks.
Green tea extra.
What's it called?
It's not green tea.
It's the,
it's the other one.
It's,
uh,
some leaf,
some leaf green leaf x.
You don't even know where you'd take.
He just grabbed things and barely stay awake and just take them.
I buy my shit on Amazon and just keep on rebuying it.
Have you ever thought it would get none like Adderall or some shit just to see
if it's for you Adderall now I don't think I need that.
Well,
I might need it a little bit,
but I,
I've tried Adderall before and it just was,
it just felt like cocaine to me.
Really?
Yeah.
I didn't help anything.
If you went to a doctor though,
I bet they'd give it to you.
Yeah.
But see you,
you've experienced me mostly super stoned out of your mind.
Like retarded stone.
I just smoked like,
I don't know how much weed.
Well,
we had to,
we had to hold up.
I mean,
when you're willing to represent we,
we were having a podcast with be real from cyber sale.
There's,
I'd love be real.
He's,
he's,
he and we had classic stoner conversation and talking about things that scared
the fuck out of us talking about a crazy animals.
And other countries.
Where are you going fella?
Oh,
well you just got up in the middle of his talking.
Didn't even say I'm going to go get some water.
So for folks who are tuned into this and like what happened to the other part of
the podcast,
the be real podcasts accidentally got
onto red bands channel,
you know,
no big deal.
He just fucked up again.
But it's all right.
And um,
it,
so it's,
but it's totally going to be available.
It just,
you,
you can't watch it live obviously cause it's over.
But it'll be available on the Ustream page and then also be available on the
Vimeo page,
which is a whatever it is.
What does it Vimeo slash calm Joe Rogan.
Just go to your website.
That's where you find all the videos.
Yeah.
Go to jail rather gun that you can find everything.
Um,
we hung out with the starter and a owner and a way.
I mean,
what does he have?
He's a founder of Ustream.
Yeah,
he was cool.
Yeah.
Brad was an Ohio state Buckeye.
Very good dude.
He was.
He was,
he was fun guy to hang out with.
Wish we had more time to hang out with them.
It was cool.
I wish I had more time.
We'll meet him again.
He's think so.
Wow.
That'd be awesome.
I also don't want to say you.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
What secrets?
No.
Can I smoke some weed from this new bond?
No,
I'm scared.
That's the jet pipe thing.
Why would you want more weed right now?
What?
That doesn't even make sense unless you're trying to do some product
endorsement.
The send it.
We'll just tell everybody about it.
Then the jet water pipe,
this is a bond that these two guys that are,
I think two guys are friends and they decided to start a company and so they
made this,
we talked about before it made like a tight,
a Dyson vacuum cleaner type bong.
Like meaning they just engineered it really well and like when you hit it you
don't take pull it.
You like push it down.
Well what it is is you don't have to put your finger over a whole anymore.
They've figured out a way to do it.
Like mechanically with a little spring.
The only question that I had was that the bowl was made out of,
uh,
what does that stuff,
what is the stuff that bowls made out of?
I don't know.
It's interesting.
It's acrylic,
right?
It's something weird.
Yeah.
I would say acrylic was that all came to light on fire and smoke.
I would wonder.
I'm sure probably figured that out.
I would hope,
but I don't know.
You know,
you never know.
And the other one,
the other question would be if they didn't,
would it be possible to make something that would fit in there that was made out
of glass where you wouldn't have that issue because somebody brought that up.
I didn't even think about it.
It's only brought it up on the message board.
Why wait?
Acrylic,
be bad.
Delight them.
It's plastic.
Or why would it be good or the melted plastic?
Well,
I don't think it melts.
I think that's the point of what God,
but what if it gets some sort of a chemical residue on your marijuana?
Is that possible?
I think it is.
Choose that.
If it was you,
I would say they wouldn't either.
But you know,
sometimes it takes a long time before people find out things do fucked up things
to them.
Like for instance,
it took them a while before they figured out that if you have um,
plastic bottles of water and they are in the sun that it actually can or you
like doing that on camera so that you uh,
so what I got a license.
They look cool.
No,
I was just showing the release thing so I didn't have to pull out the pipe like
a nice I normal bomb what he's saying it for the folks that are only listened to
this on audio instead it's got some sort of a thing in the bottom where you can
clear out the whole bong by hitting a little pull down.
She got a little little lever.
But,
um,
I mean I would assume that if it,
if,
if sun and bottled water,
if the the plastic and admit chemicals and then it gets in your bottled water
when you leave it in the sun,
then I would think that if you're heating up we'd over some plastic or acrylic,
whatever.
I mean a technically plastic.
I guess it is what it is.
I don't know what it is either but I would think that that's not good.
I didn't even think of it
by the way that the company on their website says that uh,
that the,
the bowl is ceramic code in and it works fine with the f.
You could also have 14 millimeter glass on glass attachments so that they tell
you that the size of the attachment,
you can actually put glass attachments on there if you want to do
problem solved.
There you go.
Yeah.
I would think that glass would be the way to do it cause you know the glass is
not going to melt into some residue.
It's an amazing that they make glass with fucking heat.
Think about how God damn hot it has to be.
You know,
when's the last time you saw a glass milk?
Cause you had a,
a candle over it,
you know,
it would be hot as fuck to melt glass.
Oh and I was thinking about the amino acid found in green tea earlier that I
take.
It's I think,
I mean so it's an extract.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's what I was thinking.
I'd never heard of that.
But melatonin and apparently there's a woman,
I think she was a executive of Brillstein gray,
something like that,
some big like production company or something like that.
And she was uh,
going over to Dubai for business and she got arrested for having Melatonin in
her suitcase.
Like they viewed Melatonin as a drug and another guy got arrested cause there
was some sort of an issue,
um,
with his visa.
So they made him take a drug test and he tested positive for poppy seeds because
he had a Bagel,
a poppy seed Bagel.
And that's testing positive for heroin,
poppy and heroin.
Like you can be arrested.
Poppy seed.
Yeah.
Having it like this.
I forget the lady who got some Olympic Cic,
I think I where she ate like two or three bagels a day or something like that.
And that's why she came up for that.
True.
Brian.
I think the new sophisticated tests,
well this was like 10 years ago when this happened.
Yeah.
Okay.
But anyway,
whatever it happened,
this guy got in trouble for a poppy seed Bagel and then another guy got arrested
because he had a particle of weeds stuck to the bottom of his shoe and they
detected it.
Some Rastafarian looking dude and they,
they,
uh,
arrested him like he do not fuck around.
And some countries when it comes to their drug laws,
so don't be going over there with Melatonin.
Isn't it weird that like we don't take off our shoes.
Like we walk around and we step on shit.
We step on weed,
we step on needles,
we stepped on everything and then we go and step on our carpet and then we have
our kids climb on that carpet with no nothing on it.
That crazy.
That's why Japanese take off their shoes and their houses are smarter than their
house.
I mean,
well they're all walking around with masks on and that's smarter is it?
Yeah,
no.
Do you know why?
Remember?
Yeah,
yeah.
But for folks who don't know because they road works with us,
um,
they planted a lot according to our driver.
This is,
and we've done no outside research whatsoever,
but he said the reason why all these people were wearing surgical masks,
a big part of it was hay fever that they got from Cedar Allergies,
like Hay fever or some sort of a cedar allergy.
And that Cedar trees were introduced to Japan after World War II and 30% as many
as 30% of Japanese people are allergic to Cedar.
And that's because they burn in the ward.
They burned down in their houses and you had the big fire of Japan and they had
to rebuild other houses.
I think they,
they planted those trees did because they had too many houses to,
to read,
to make and people are allergic to Cedar.
It's really crazy also that it was because,
uh,
they also feel that like if you have a code,
like if you are going to work sneezing Alito,
that you should wear one that's your responsibility and it's,
it's uh,
it's rude if you sneeze without one of these on.
So that's why it's weird walking around.
It's like probably 30 or 40% of the people look like they just had this mass on.
Oh yeah.
There was a weird,
it was very different than us.
They're like,
again,
their,
their culture is like,
you have to take care of your own shit and you're much more polite.
We saw no homeless people whatsoever.
None.
Zero.
It was really interesting.
And the cops are on these little stations and they just sit at a desk,
like a help desk.
Like kind of like when you go to a mall and they have like that little desk
where you can,
you know,
that's kind of like,
I got lost at one,
one point and I wasted,
went to this cop and he drew me a map.
He spoke no English.
I spoke no Japanese and he knew what I was trying to do and sent me to the wrong
hotel and I walked two extra miles.
But uh,
he still spent the time to draw me a map to the wrong hotel at least.
Yeah.
No,
they're super helpful.
It's different.
Why don't you fucking move to,
I would,
I wouldn't move to Japan.
You won't gave floaters and you want to live in Japan.
Go Big in Japan.
We met a lot of podcast fans that lived in Japan,
which has a lot of people that came to the fights.
That's one of the coolest things about the podcast.
It's available everywhere.
It's free.
Get,
it's not,
you know,
it's not a reach.
We will make it as available as possible.
So glad that we did that because it totally turned out to be the right move.
My mom saw me on TV.
My mom was flipping through the channels and just happened to me on the fights
and the audience on like spike or not affects,
what is it on now?
Yeah,
FX.
Fx.
And she went,
my mom's like,
Holy Shit.
That's Brian Wright on the TV,
and so she watched me.
But what's so funny is how quiet it was,
and it's one of the fans though,
red band,
and it was like everybody could hear it in the whole place.
He goes all of garden and the whole thing.
Everyone heard that.
That's how quiet was it?
Yeah,
you don't really,
you,
you could not imagine if you've never been to a Japanese sporting event,
how quiet it can be while the fight is going on,
how respectful they are.
It's amazing.
I love,
would you,
do you want to go back to Japan?
I would do it,
but I like Brazil too,
man.
Brazil,
they go nuts.
We,
I did lots of wild too.
I don't know,
man.
Brazil was fun.
People were very nice to,
food was fantastic.
People were really fun and friendly.
It was a total opposite.
As far as like the outgoingness people are very outgoing and although very
friendly as well in Brazil,
just much more outgoing and loud and having fun,
laughing a lot.
I might have more fun in Brazil than in Japan.
I'm on team Japan.
Brazil,
they're not going to make you cover every tattoos if you want to go swimming.
You know what I'm saying?
They're more laid back.
It's more of my kind of place and although Japan was amazing,
you know,
but the overall look overall,
one of the things about traveling and one of the things that I find that when I
come back,
it's America is the shit,
what a great place to live.
There's so much cool stuff here as far as like cool,
like bands to see cool art,
to see cool comics,
to see cool movies every way you go.
By the way,
they're fucking American movies that are dubbed over in other countries.
I mean in Japan we went to the movie theater.
It was like four out of five movies were American movies that had been dubbed
over in Japanese and all the posters were slightly changed.
Like,
like the mission impossible poster looks slightly changed.
I think that would make it look more like he was Japanese and stuff.
It was awesome.
Well it was a little bit in the shadows a little bit,
but he like,
it's fucking awesome.
Awesome hanging out there.
No doubt.
But America is my favorite fucking country ever.
Even though it's fucked up and corrupt and filled with Conn's at the very top
what it embodies as far as like what we're capable of producing.
You know America produces some fucking fun shit.
A lot of fun art man.
Like,
like I told you when I see,
when I saw honey honey last night I was like God damn,
this is like a,
they're like such an American bad ass creative band.
But it's,
it's so like the style is so American,
you know,
there's so many good parts of this country,
as far as like as like standup comedy goes and it's like,
you know,
movies and art work
stop that fine.
But we're run by cons.
It's like you've got to figure out a way to balance that out.
I wonder if that's the only way you can get so many crazy wild creative people
in a spot.
You have to have it be run like cuts and the cuts that run it,
they suppress everybody and every art just blossoms out of that suppression left
and right.
Because when I go to a place like Japan,
it's so polite and so nice and they so they're so disciplined and I'm like,
man,
yeah,
but when was the last time,
you know,
you saw like how many people were lining up for Japanese standup comedy?
I mean,
is it,
is it really popular all over the world,
you know,
is there like master Japanese musicians that we don't know about?
You know,
I mean is why is it everywhere we're going,
we're listening to American music.
Is it that the way to get really popular,
really exciting artwork is to suppress the,
the,
the youth early on.
So they're fighting against it and that's where rock and roll comes from a
rebellion.
And that's where the,
the truth that very few people would have the balls to say.
Is that where it comes from?
Does it come from fighting against someone who suppressing you and does it not
come naturally when everybody is respectful?
Like the Japanese?
I don't know.
I'm just asking.
I'm just trying to be like a social scientist checking this all out.
But it is fascinating when you see like
there's no way of making a Joey d as in Japan.
You know what I'm saying?
That would be kind of
Cortisiaga a cock sucker.
Yeah,
I left not lesson.
What is the,
we don't care if it's illegal down to your cock sock.
I know you got it.
No,
it's 2012 nobody surviving and what are we dog?
Nobody.
Not any spot on the globe.
Nice.
Polite as possible.
I'm here to help you.
That would be funny if he went to a different sounding high,
like his voice got really high to me
as it goes on.
Yeah.
That's really sucks that Joey can't go to other countries because of his record
when he was young.
Can you imagine him in Japan?
That would be
bring him to England.
They would never have them in England and they can't.
They wouldn't have them in Canada.
No Way.
Cannabis really strict.
You know Canada is like a boat over a sea of Douche bags,
you know?
I mean,
and again,
ladies and gentlemen of America,
I just told you how much I love America.
America is not all Douche bags.
It's a small percentage,
but there's a lot of us.
So if there's 300 million people in,
10% of the people are douchebags do the math.
That's a lot of Goddamn Douche bags,
you know?
Would you want that bubbling underneath you sneaking across the borders to fuck
your woman light things on fire then sneak back over in the night.
No.
Got To check out people's fucking records and anybody even remotely shady.
Canada's like,
Nah,
we're good.
We're good.
Drunk driving nap,
nap.
We're good.
I only did it once.
Yep.
That's okay.
Bye Bye.
I go back home.
Get out of here.
You did your,
you're a crazy person.
You're affiliated with crazy activity.
You've fucked something up.
Too Bad.
We couldn't do comedy in Japan would have been fascinating,
but we might've got arrested when we started talking about flinging Lowe's on
the hotel.
Which hotel?
You know,
you talk,
all the people would be thinking like,
oh my God,
what if I'm staying in the hotel with this guy's fleeing loads in the walls,
right?
Breast.
You don't say that,
Brian.
Oh No,
I'm responsible for you taking care of your fucking hotel realm.
It's undermined credit card.
Don't go around Saturday and spine deep file.
Okay.
Will you make it clear that you didn't cause it goes out on the Internet?
I definitely did not.
Spiderman in Japan.
Don't ever do that.
Now when you're staying with me I want to get arrested to the maid walks in at
the exact moment and she has her.
I open when your load falls from the ceiling and she doesn't expect and it drops
right in her eye and she gets I aid street.
Yeah.
Cheat for my face.
She gets some I aids from your dirty rotten com six hour km long dead sperms.
How long has this berms live outside the body and you should find that can
choose your load on a girl's tits and could she stuffed it in her pussy and get
pregnant?
Yeah.
See I always wondered about,
there was definitely times where like in the past where like I would have sex
and then we need to find that out.
I like,
I would like take off the condom and just throw it on the ground or something
like that.
And then I thought like,
I just left her house.
What if she took that calm and she wanted a baby so much that she just like
starts stuffing it in her pussy and my girl who did that.
Really?
Yeah.
It was a sister of a girl that I knew.
Did that.
She saved the condom and she uh,
she tried to stuff it back inside of our body.
How long does it last?
She stuffed it back in and she told her sister she was stopped at her on her
body after the guy left.
Wow.
Um,
how long does sperm live after ejaculation?
Let's find out,
shall it?
It says the lifespan of sperm after ejaculation depends on environmental
conditions.
Permit Jack played into a woman's vagina can live in a woman's reproductive
track for up to five days or perhaps even longer days.
Fertilization is possible as long as the sperm remains alive.
I need to make bird call.
Jackie waited outside the body may only survive minutes to a few hours,
may survive only minutes to a few hours.
So if you've got some crazy survivorman sperm,
they might be able to last for hours and she could scoop it out of her condom
and stuff it in her box.
And then you got a baby,
whether you like it or not.
All she needs is a Turkey baster.
Stick it up in their little twat and,
and that's it.
So you got to tie up your sperm.
You know what you should do,
your stove a sacrifice.
You should bring lighter fluid everywhere.
Every time you fuck.
So it'd be such a bad ass move.
After you fuck a girl,
you pull a condom off,
he tied at the end,
you throw in the sink,
lighter fluid on it,
and you'd throw a match on it.
You walk away with your back to it
or tie it into the entire night in the condom and just bite it and burst in your
mouth.
You got to turn your back.
Like that scene in Wolverine,
we blew up the car behind him.
The explosion,
like the fear factor demos where they had me like standing there and this
explosion behind me and I was supposed to look like no big deal.
That's just an explosion behind me.
Dot.
I part of what the things that I was doing when I was,
um,
uh,
doing those promos,
I was doing a couple of them.
I was thinking,
God,
I can't wait cause if this show gets cancelled,
I have so much new material.
My God,
it's one of the reasons why I can't wait for two things.
One,
I can't wait until I start my new special because,
uh,
um,
on April 20th in Atlanta,
I'm going to,
I've decided I'm going to do that.
Um,
um,
my,
my special where I'm going to film it.
Yeah.
It should be fun.
And when I decided that I decided well,
as soon as fear factors officially fucking totally,
absolutely.
When will you know it?
When I think it is,
I think I've gotten an email from them saying that it is,
but I don't know if I can talk shit about it yet.
I don't know.
Probably like a three year cause no,
I have to find out and it wouldn't be shit.
I mean negative shit,
but it would be,
uh,
there's so many interesting things to talk about
though.
It was a fascinating thing to do that this,
this was one of the weirder seasons.
Like while I was doing a lot of things,
I was like,
wow,
I can't wait to talk about this.
This one's,
this is fucking nuts behind the scene.
That's all of it.
Just weird.
So fucking weird gig man.
To do it again after five years was so surreal.
And if it's not cancer,
it's not canceled.
I'm going to be forced to do more of them.
You know,
I'd be happy just to have everybody back together and do a show that I think
some people liked.
But if it doesn't do it,
I'm happy with that too.
I actually,
even though it's a great job,
it's still a job.
Like there's such a difference between doing a podcast,
doing standup comedy and doing the UFC and then going and doing a job.
You know,
when you go and do a job,
it's like,
it's awesome to have this job.
Like Holy Shit,
what a great job.
But man,
there's nothing like live in a life where you just follow your passions.
And one of the things I started realizing when I started doing Fairfax,
I was like,
damn,
I heard he had it nailed.
I already had it where I was like,
everything I was doing I enjoyed.
I wasn't really working.
I was just at my time,
was committed doing all this cool stuff,
but in fact,
none of it was working,
you know?
Although I,
you know,
I take my job at the UFC very seriously and I,
it's an honor to work then I love calling fights.
I don't even,
I don't even like other sports.
That's how much I love doing it.
It's still,
when,
when I get there and do it,
it never feels like work.
Never.
It's,
it's like it,
there's never a moment when like a fight about to begin where I wish I was
somewhere else.
It's so fucking fun and crazy,
you know?
So to be able to do that.
That's a job.
And then stand up comedy.
Same thing.
I mean,
how much fun is stand up,
you know?
It's that you're doing it now.
You know what it's like.
It's fun as hell.
The,
the act of making people laugh,
you're making them feel better.
You're making them happy,
you're giving them like a charge of good energy,
you know?
And I'm addicted to it too,
but there's nothing more fun than watching.
Like your friends kill and you're fucking howling at some new bit and you're
like,
oh shit.
Did you hear his new bit?
Like Dunkin fucking floor to me?
I don't want to say the bit,
I don't want to say the bit because I want people to see it this weekend and I
want to,
I don't want to even give up the premise because it's one of those,
when you start giving up the premise,
you give up a lot of the power of the joke,
but God damn,
I heard it and I was like,
holy fuck,
that's good.
I love comedy.
So most fun fucking thing.
It really is.
We're so lucky.
It makes you wonder for in the Matrix,
it makes you wonder,
you know,
maybe we're like Joey pants and we just made some fucking crazy deal to have.
All right.
I want to work,
but I want everything to be cool.
Everything I do,
it's gotta be fun.
No,
no,
no jobs.
It's suck.
It's impossible for everybody to do that though.
That's a real problem.
You can't have a society based on everybody doing awesome shit.
Unless what?
Everybody's awesome shit varies,
right?
Like some people,
it's gotta be awesome to work at in and out Burger,
you know what I mean?
Or No,
right.
Because that's like part of the process of becoming whoever the fuck you want to
become.
You have to go through some shit,
menial jobs.
Cut An understand what Labor's really like or find it or find out what you want
to do.
I think that that's more of it.
Like I grew up most of my life,
like what do I want to do?
Really like I like to draw.
That's all I like to,
that's all I can say.
You know,
I have to thank a fucking high school art teacher for being a Douche bag.
Cause if it wasn't for him being a Douche bag,
I probably never would've became a fighter or a comic.
You know,
I wanted to be an artist but my,
my high school art teacher.
Imagine lamb.
Imagine rewinding your life and you live in your life as an artist.
You what if you were like bad ass crazy artists?
I would have enjoyed it just to look.
I think I would enjoy life period.
But I definitely would have,
I think one of the most important things for me,
for my body type,
my brain type is to find some exertion,
martial arts.
Something where physically exert myself.
Yoga,
something where I you I figure out something to center my body.
The only thing that I would ever worry about doing something like,
you know,
uh,
being an artist is a,
you're,
you're sitting at a desk a lot of hours.
Sure.
All upside down.
No,
stop it.
I feel it when I write,
when I write for like a a couple of days in a row when I'm like working on some
shit.
You know,
I feel like after sitting in front of a computer for a long period of time,
I feel super uncomfortable.
My next starts fucking crack and I started moving and pop and shit just not
healthy.
You remember when we were coming back,
we were looking at these guys at a,
in La when you land,
you know there's the Tsa,
they have a Goddamn laboratory out where they're checking your food.
You know the,
the contrast between the way they are in Japan,
the way they are in America is really stark.
It's really obvious.
They had like microscopes and shit and beakers and for refrigerators and I mean
it was really nuts.
They were,
they were testing things and the pulling people's strawberries apart,
chopping them up and throwing them into some fucking blender,
pouring things on them.
I don't know if it was a blender,
I think it was like some kind of light that they were seeing how it reacts to
like a light to see if there's any growth on something or,
yeah,
there was a little of that,
there were babies for the solution on it too.
I don't know what the solution was,
but you know,
everybody's like super suspicious.
Like they're,
they,
they opened up every little piece of all these little people's luggage,
you know,
and it was always people for they look small or brownish sort of people that
looked like,
you know,
they came from somewhere like South America may be,
or Mexico or something like that,
or Miami or could be Miami,
Miami,
they're tall and Tan.
Then,
uh,
as compact.
These are like compact,
like hardworking people.
And they were checking their fruit.
You know,
they wanted to bring home some goddamn fruit,
but I don't think you're allowed to.
Yeah,
they were cutting the fruit up and looking at every single piece.
So we just so weird that we have fucking,
I mean it's important I guess because the rest of the world's kind of wacky and
there's a lot of spots that like we were talking about Africa early or,
and you know any part of the world.
It's in turmoil right now.
This is,
you know,
you gotta,
you gotta check,
make sure you're allowing good people to come over here.
You don't want a bunch of fucking nut bags come over here and ruin what we've
got,
which is pretty sweet.
But man,
what a stark contrast it is to Japan,
Japan.
They're so happy to see you.
Hello?
Hello.
You're like,
yeah,
I'm not a criminal.
You're right.
I'm just coming here to work.
Thank you.
Oh,
it's okay.
Yeah.
My papers are in order.
No,
I don't.
I don't have any fruit.
Come on man.
Have a good day.
Everybody's Super Nice.
What would you go move there and so Golar Dixon peace sign,
bro.
Fucking love it.
I want to go back that flight smile member crew member tea milk or what did I
drink?
Oh yeah,
no,
no cheat.
He grabs something that looked like Thai iced coffee.
Yeah,
tires.
Coffee's delicious.
Delicious.
It looked like that.
It looked like this is probably like a Chocolatey,
delicious sort of coffee.
Sweet.
No ass.
Yeah.
When I say it tastes like straight up mulchers leaves.
Oh,
a hundred percent leave.
Remember window.
We went and got Sushi.
We had like the freshest,
most radioactive Sushi.
It was delicious.
At first we were like all scare,
like great,
don't eat fruits and vegetables.
All right.
Yeah,
let's not do that.
I was like,
listen man,
I'm just eating whatever the fuck I eat.
I take some potassium iodine and I'll be good.
He showed us also day or drivers showed us that Tokyo Tower is crooked at the
very top.
It was crooked from the,
well,
there's wires to support it because the earth earthquake you started falling
over so they had a support it with wires.
So yeah,
it's pretty fucking crazy.
The earthquake move,
that thing know they have a lot of earthquakes there.
That is something that they have to deal with and Tokyo and Mount Fiji.
Bryan count told me may or may not patrol,
but Brian Cowen told me and totally makes sense that the reason why they had,
they used to have paper houses there is because they have so many months hoons
and typhoons.
He didn't want your fucking house falling on you and killing you in the middle
of the night because they had no accurate way of predicting the weather.
So what they would do is they would just create very light houses.
So if you get hit in the head with some Balsa Wood and paper,
you're going to live and that wakes you up,
you know,
and then you're like,
oh,
I gotta get Outta here.
And then you,
you know,
go to an underground location or some shit is that way.
Japanese girls like have sex.
Like,
because you didn't know how they have to find these curls,
have some porno.
But because,
because the walls are so thin,
they had to sound like chipmunks or something outside because you would hear
people have sex.
I was in my hotel room and I was flipping through the channels and it was really
interesting because it was all Japanese television and,
but there was English menus and one of the,
one of the menu items said pay.
So I said,
all right,
well this either how to pay my hotel bill or it's movies.
And so I click on pay and it immediately opens up with a dude with an Anana
anonymous mask banging a check and everything below the hips is blurry.
Like you can't see her,
her pussy,
you can't see his deck.
There's this a mass of blurriness there.
And he's just like,
he's like hitting it,
but he's,
he's not hitting it.
Like he's got a big deck.
He sit and eat,
like he's got a little Dick.
So he's hitting it hard,
but the strokes are super small.
But he was just like this and he had a mask on.
So he's this mask on and he's like,
that's pay.
And that was on my bill.
I saw that was on my bill pay pay movie.
Yeah,
I paid for that.
I didn't know what it was.
I,
that's how I would get a menu when I went,
when I go through the menu and it says,
you know,
here's your options.
This,
this,
maybe there's some good movies you have to pay for.
So I clicked.
It doesn't say adults that just says,
hey.
Yeah,
so,
uh,
I wound up watching this guy with an anonymous,
I only watch it for a few seconds for it come all over herself.
That's a screaming like a fucking Apache on a warpath.
I watched it.
I'd set the TV at an angle and I set up a day on and I just beat off and hit the
ceiling.
No,
I only watch it for,
I wasn't looking for,
I get that on the Internet.
Well,
I want to wash their strap to fit so crappy.
It was terrible.
They couldn't,
you couldn't,
you're not allowed to look at pussies.
It's like somehow or another,
they,
somebody tricked them into thinking that the thing that you want to look at is
bad,
but you can know what they're doing.
But it all has to be all blurry down.
They're like,
wait a minute.
Pixelation was pixelation the green light for pornography.
Didn't they have pornography before pixilation was available?
What did they do?
Did they just never focused on the pussy?
Did one girl not like the way her pussy looked and she talks him fucking emperor
and to making it so it's a law.
You can't see a girl's pussy.
I think it's just disrespectful.
Is it?
Or is it dudes that are really ashamed of their tiny little decks and so they
just want it all blurred out.
It could be my jack had,
could be gin.
You know what I did watch this weekend?
It was pretty giant.
The,
Oh,
I saw the Kim Kardashians sex tape.
Somebody put it up on the message board.
I'd actually never seen it before.
It's great.
I never watched it.
Pretty powerful.
Well,
what's powerful is the size.
That guy's cock.
Holy Shit.
Cause she really got fucked in it.
That's what I like about that young man has a goddamn weapon.
Yeah,
he's got a big duck,
but she wasn't doing such a good job of sucking it.
She's mostly hands,
trickery,
supposedly trickery.
Why do you like blow job videos?
Why do you care what anybody likes?
You weirdo.
You get upset if somebody likes something that you don't like.
Blowjobs Oh,
do you understand?
Do you understand that for most men,
blow jobs are like the epitome of pleasure.
I never blow job.
They liked it.
Why is that?
Why is that weird?
Why 70% cockies you're like,
why is that weird when you're watching guys,
fuck.
Do you only like concentrate on the woman?
Like I like seeing the girl definitely get fucked.
But like with a blowjob video,
it's all about this like looking around it and cleaning it and it's not really
all about pretending it's your dick stupid.
You got a shitty way of looking at it either way.
That's not you fucking that girl either.
Do you see him whimpering?
No,
that's not you.
Do you see him?
Just three strokes and out of breath.
And that's how you,
you know,
there's nothing like watching a guy have a girl fingers Bible.
Why watch guys fuck it all.
Why not just all watch only lesbian porno and so managed.
If Dad was waiting for me on a planet somewhere and I was the only man and they
would all be mine,
they would fight over me while she's using the plastic.
Just waiting,
waiting for you to land on your little raft.
Isn't that like a,
what is
that?
What you got there?
You got to a desk.
They look it's brass knuckles on one side and then a dildo on the other one.
What is the brass knuckles are made out of plastic,
Huh?
Yeah.
So there's two different types of plastic.
There's a softer plastic that goes into a box.
Hard accident.
Is it bad?
It's not.
It's hard rubber.
But then you,
you like just fuck her placing.
Where did you get this?
I bought it,
but where I'm not just saying in Japan.
No.
So,
um,
you,
you've got to use that on a Rodin.
No,
you have two girls do it for you.
Oh,
and you stick it up your ass.
Is that what you're saying?
I know you just,
you want to soccer.
What do you want to do now?
You just,
you know,
slap in the face with you want to get slapped while you're doing it.
Oh,
okay.
So you,
you slapped him in the face where your Dick while you pretend you're fucking
with a giant bark fucking each other with that.
Oh,
okay.
That seems silly.
It seems like you're missing the point of sex.
You let letting some big rubber dick take over your turf.
The Rubber Dick is getting late and you're just slapping girls' in the face with
your cock.
That's ridiculous.
The best thing is to get laid,
Brian.
And you've given that to a plastic deck you've like,
yeah,
well I know that it can never be as good as that.
So just let her use the fake Dick and I'll just get my pleasure off on her face.
Is that what it is now?
I just get them all worked up until they need a real dick.
Oh really?
So what's this all about?
Foreplay that giant fake Dick just gets them worked up thinking about,
man,
there's a diff out there.
There's this big as this.
I need to find that dig.
It becomes like Indiana Jones.
And the last Dick,
when a women find out that it's possible that that giant Dildo could be on a
man,
she's like,
maybe I could love him.
Maybe it's like my dream,
man.
I don't even know.
I'm just wasting my time with this average Dick Loser.
It makes it easier for them to have a baby and they appreciate you fucking them
with that and stretching it out for them.
Hmm.
I don't think so.
I don't think any girl looks at it like that.
I think she wishes it was a real dick.
That's what she thinks she wishes.
God dammit.
It's probably some genetic thing inside their body that must feel so much better
when the JIC his dick is just gigantic.
That's why people have to say shit like size doesn't matter.
That's ridiculous.
Of course it matters.
How could you say that?
It's so foolish?
I think foolish,
foolish to say,
well,
it's something that creates more frictions.
Larger,
it wouldn't be better.
Well,
I,
I do say that there is something to a certain point,
I don't think there's much of a difference if it's fat and to a certain point,
I think it hits a certain spot.
Even if it's larger.
It doesn't need to be larger,
especially the girl in the butter.
Some girls do.
You're crazy.
I think I'm sure that's not even an option.
I mean like,
like if it's like,
like hey,
do you want eight inches or do you want 14 I think they would rather say eight
inches.
Yeah.
That's a good point.
That there's a certain point where it starts hurting.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's some girls that don't enjoy having sex with guys cause they're just
slamming into their cervix.
Yeah.
So the end,
they were like trying to stretch out their fucking,
their drama at the end ball,
the meat drum at the end of slamming into it.
That's why you have cock rings and you know that's like washers for the girls.
Assholes so stops you at a certain point,
like a doorstop so you won't hurt their per girl.
Your lover.
You've got to find how many rings you need.
Good move.
Cock ring stoppers.
Yeah,
washers,
washers live on that part of your deck would always be sad.
That party of Dick would always be sad like what about us?
What squirts do you still in there?
The whole Dick wants in on the action and the PR.
Apparently the deepest part of your Dick is oftentimes the most sensitive,
which is why it's camped out next to your balls.
It's like super sensitive,
just like your balls.
That's why it feels so good to go all the way in there and what it is is is
mother nature trying to set you up so that you definitely have kids,
Mother Nature trying to pitch the sperm as close to the eggs as possible.
Knowing that these Rambo spermatozoa does have a five day lifespan.
If they're the like the best navy seal type hold their breath sperm ever.
That's crazy.
About five days because sometimes I'd be like,
all right baby,
since you're on your period,
I'm going to come in you,
you know,
and then you're like,
wait,
she in five days she might be offered period.
There might still be commonary.
She hasn't.
Yeah.
That's why the the rhythm method,
it's very tricky and shooting the load inside of chick cause you're pretty sure
she's not ambulating.
Ooh,
that's tricky son.
That's why Irish people have so many kids.
It's a lot of it.
The rhythm method,
those are the,
for Real Irish Catholic,
you know,
Catholics,
Catholics aren't supposed to use birth control.
Birth control is not good,
Huh?
Yeah.
Isn't that funny?
It's hilarious.
I mean,
think about all these overpopulated places in Latin America,
Mexico,
Catholics,
you know,
and they don't want to use birth control.
Okay.
It's pretty ridiculous.
That's a bunch of hate or bullshit stop and guy from using a condom.
How dare you
like it.
Like if you come on something and then it girl sits on it,
are you responsible for that child?
It's a good question.
A bet you are.
I bet if you came on a table and she scooped it up and stuffed in there snatch,
I bet she could probably say,
you know,
hey,
this is what he wanted.
This fantasy was for me to get pregnant by stealing his berm.
That seems as crazy that you have to have responsibility for liquid.
Well,
it's crazy that you have to have responsibility for a chemical process that
results in our life.
When if you,
if someone stole your sperm or if he just like,
you know,
like comed on a bed and then you had a friend over and she took off her clothes.
It wasn't your intention to get a girl pregnant.
Yeah.
You shouldn't be responsible,
but then you would have to have like a transcript so that night to approve or
you didn't actually just come inside of her and just go,
oh in the,
yeah,
that should be proved either way.
You know meaning like if you're going to say that you had sex,
you have to have proof for that.
Awesome.
Instead of half time when people have sperming and once cause they had socks.
Pride.
Yeah.
I know.
It seems to be the thing that you shouldn't have to prove in court though.
You think or you would have to prove it either way.
That's doesn't seem fair to the girl.
How's she gonna prove that?
Then girls would just start to setting up cameras.
Hidden cameras.
Guys prove that.
She just sat on your comment where it was on her bed.
Well,
you'd have to have a video.
You ejaculate on the bed and then like some hidden camera.
We should have be able to us having sex then
for the same reason.
Well,
imagine if it comes down to that.
Imagine comes down to every time you have sex you have to record it.
Just so everybody knows that no rape crimes took place.
Nothing creepy took place.
So the government would have just like a massive database of people fucking just
make sure,
look,
we had some behind closed doors,
rapes going on and we had to stop them because of like 10 rapes in a city.
Everybody has to get their self film while they fuck no purposes.
You're allowed to view.
And could you imagine if you had one of those clips on that you were,
you know,
that fit clip thing that you were?
Imagine if it's like,
you know your,
your heartbeat gets jacked up like 160 beats per minute.
They're like,
okay Mr Ryko,
are you having sex or you at the gym?
Please respond like you gotta make sure you're not fucking dude.
Cause if you're not fucking,
no one can watch.
How come,
how come you fucking in the dark?
You're supposed to be in front of the camera now,
sir.
You're fit clips has it.
Your heart rate is elevated.
That's funny.
Yeah.
Every,
all the fucking you do.
You can ever rape anybody in the closet.
No,
no,
no.
That's,
that's gonna be the next thing.
There's going to be a way to monitor your state of consciousness,
your heart rate,
your,
your blood sugar levels,
all that shit.
You gotta be able monitor it constantly on a person's body.
Just makes sense.
Like some sort of an implant.
So the implant will just read the various variables in your body and then
interface with some sort of a computer.
You'll walk in front of,
somebody will scan it and it'll just read back the information.
You think about how small computers are now compared to how big they were when
NASA launched the Apollo missions.
And then think of how small they are going to be in the future.
They're going to be injectable,
going to have a computer that you can inject into your fucking ass.
Just a little,
like a hard,
like it would be like a tiny,
tiny half size grain of rice,
half a grain of rice.
It's already been putting in your ass.
Yeah.
Doctors had been paid to give it to you.
That's what people think of.
Believe in aliens.
You know,
believes in aliens.
Edgar Mitchell,
former astronauts guy walked on the moon,
so he believes in aliens whom some big fucking press conference.
I think there's not a press conference,
but an interview.
He did an interview where he was saying that,
uh,
he,
um,
he knows that the government has access to information and that he can prove or
lease.
He believes to the best of his knowledge that the government is a received
transmissions from aliens.
Been in communication with them.
They know that they're watching us.
They know that they're hovering around earth.
It was kind of interesting watching this guy with his fucking dog is like his
dog sitting in his lap.
It's Kinda cute.
Here's a little terrier,
and he's talking about,
it's talking about Ufo woes and all these different things that the government
knows exists and you're like,
whoa,
is this kind of lost his marbles or is he telling the truth?
And he's like,
I don't give a fuck anymore.
I got my dog here.
I'm 18 fucking years old.
I'm just going to tell people and no one's probably going to believe me,
but hey,
whatever.
You know when your thing,
there was a really cool dog breeding at that's in Japan.
I've been researching a lot now because it's,
you only really see it in Japan.
But I saw one on the street and it looks so weird.
It looks like a Fox mixed with the cat and it was a bred to hunt,
uh,
bears by the Japanese and it's a cold,
I think it's called Sheebu.
He move or something like that.
She will hold on,
you know,
that's my,
one of my dogs.
My dogs is half sheet.
Yeah,
he's got a little bit of content him.
He's a nice,
he's a sweet ed,
but he's,
he's,
he's confused.
He's a sweetheart.
But he's confused cause he's half bull dog.
Half she will,
you know,
so he doesn't know what the hell he is.
He doesn't know whether to be lazy or whether it be like a little cunty.
Yeah,
he's a sweetheart though.
Like he's really like really nice.
Like it's as far as like when you come out to him,
he always wants to be pat is that he's a nice dog but he gets a little snappy
with people.
Yeah.
I guess that the breed is kind of like very protective of just the family but
also like,
you know,
they're just like,
he like complete assholes but it's,
we're really weird facial expressions.
Like this chick that was walking the dog in Japan,
she was like about to turn this corner and the dog wouldn't go.
Just stopped and looked at her at this face like,
hey,
I need to go take a shit over there.
And immediately he,
she was like,
oh I'm sorry.
And she said sorry.
And then we like went to the grass and he took a ship.
But it was weird.
The face.
Well animated
dogs or the dogs that are a,
usually the smartest,
you know the,
the,
the smartest dogs.
The dogs go,
hey,
you got a problem here.
You know like German shepherds and Shit,
wolves,
those dogs does it smart as fuck man.
And they're the ones that a lot of times cause problems.
They escape a lot,
you know,
cause they get bored.
What's that Brita dog at my friend Pete has this dog,
that one word that there's a thing down its back that grows the opposite
direction.
The hair grows.
The yeah.
Is a ridgeback and manage things intimidating to be around as it really has a
solid dog.
Like I'm more scared of that dog than I am pimple.
Wow.
That's crazy.
I don't know.
Just some,
some around it.
Like it looks like it's,
it could,
it,
it looks like a,
check your email real quick.
I sent you that Edgar Mitchell video.
Oh there they're more of a slender dog man.
Yeah.
But addition,
written backs,
all muscle.
They're very,
very athletic guard dog style.
The scariest dogs are the big ones.
Those,
those are the ones that can tell you it's huge.
You know,
it's,
it's a hunt lions,
they're decent bridge back shot up.
Like this thing's humongous.
Let's look up,
cause I'm pretty sure they only get to be about 80 or 90 pounds.
Just things stood was taller than me standing up.
It was like Marma Duke,
our muscles a muscular Marmaduke.
That's what it reminded me of.
Like a dog that would be in the video.
Can Russian attack?
Really?
Yeah.
That big.
No Dude,
they're kind of a slender
dog.
I'm looking at him right now,
man.
I think you're confusing this with somebody.
I think we're,
we're communicating about different dogs.
This is the one that has a,
a line that goes down at back that goes a different direction.
It ridgeback.
Yeah.
Well there's,
I guess there's one that's in here that looks kind of muscular,
but they seem very thin.
Okay.
Um,
so I'm trying to figure out how big they get.
Uh,
does it appearance?
Here we go.
Oh,
they call him the lion hunter.
70 pounds,
bro.
Okay.
Oh,
okay.
No,
no,
no way.
About 80 males weigh about 85 pounds.
Okay.
She'll be 2,102 to too many or much larger.
Which backs are typical muscular.
Okay.
So I guess even though some of them are like 85 pounds,
they're saying some of them get way bigger.
Check this out.
So I would imagine if you ran into a hundred pounder,
yeah,
that'd be a big fucking dog.
Check this out.
That's a Rhodesian Brewster,
amazing dogs
to walk the face of the earth.
Also known as the African Lion Dog.
The Rhodesian ridgeback is a large muscular dog bred in southern Africa to hunt
lions.
Whoa.
You know that term keeping a line at bay?
Well,
that came from the Rhodesian ridgebacks.
The breed was created by hot and tots and indigenous people of South Africa and
early German and Dutch settlers.
They combined imported mastiffs great Danes,
greyhounds,
bloodhounds terriers and other breeds,
the heart and top dog,
a semi wild tribal guarding and hunting dog to create the Rhodesian ridgeback.
Imagine the type of personality it takes to run after a seven 800 pound cat and,
and chase it up a tree.
And that's the Rhodesian ridgeback.
The most unique and defining characteristics of the Rhodesian ridgeback is,
is rich.
He can thank the wild hot and Todd dog for that.
It's basically hair going in the opposite direction of the hair that grows down
the rest of their body.
The Ridge should be clearly defined.
It's like an empire dogs back.
Do you remember where we ran into that girl
who works with the UFC who has a dog like my dog?
Only 50 fucking pounds bigger.
Yeah,
that 200 pound.
Massive.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
That dog was so ridiculous and really sweet and were there.
They're really sweet,
gentle dogs,
but like when I like touch,
the dog just wanted me to take a picture with him.
I put my arm around him,
I was like next to him and he would like move a little like bump into me and I'd
be like,
oh Jesus.
Like you're standing,
you're standing next to a giant animal.
It's really big.
It's bigger than me and it's a dog and it's these enormous fucking head on him.
Oh my God.
That thing was ridiculous.
200 pounds and she flies.
It goes in a plane.
Wow.
Isn't the cargo holds somehow or another with this giant box?
It stays it.
That's so rude to fly with animals.
I think dog didn't seem to give a fuck.
I think she did it so often.
He was just used to it.
Have you ever been around somebody that their ears pop during a flight?
Yeah.
That's so great.
Well,
you know what else else happens if you have any sort of a sinus infection,
it's unbelievably painful in your ears when you get to high altitude,
when you coming down and when you're coming down somehow or another,
that's when your ears start popping and it's excruciating fucking pain.
Sinus pain that that deep ear sinus pain when you're all,
your whole inside is clogged and affected.
Ooh,
that's not good on a plane.
Okay.
Planes are fucking freaky dude.
What's going to be next though is they're going to be like the ever going to be
a Concord again.
They're ever going to go with supersonic travel or is it just too dangerous?
I don't know.
I just don't like flying over the ocean.
And when you go that fast in birds even get out of your way,
do they even have time to get out of your way?
Yeah.
So if you slam it a birds,
is that a wrap?
Yeah.
If you like taking off off the fucking lax and you're in a Concorde and you're
launching through the fucking air,
you hit like supersonic speeds.
Berg.
That pursuit dad is fuck right.
Yup.
And you'd probably have to take off really fast with those things too.
It's not like you have the option to take off slow.
Right.
The wants the coast is clear.
Then you rock it,
dude.
No,
I think you have to take off fast at the beginning.
That's amazing though.
Have you ever watched him in the footage of the Concorde?
Yeah,
they were washed it.
Yeah.
It's incredible to pull up the video of the Concord so we could see what it
looks like.
Not a Concorde exploding though.
That's shit's depressing.
Oh,
that's what happened.
A bunch of them exploded.
Why?
Well,
one of them hit a tire than another.
A plane had left behind on the runway,
so as it was accelerating it hit a tire and the tire kicked up and slammed into
the plane and cause it to be on fire as they were in the air.
Look at that fucking thing,
man.
That's what a lot of people thought.
I think they came out in the 80s is that correct?
I think so,
yeah.
Let me see.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm sorry.
I don't
Concord's creep was they did them for a little while and then it got to a point
where you know too many people there were malfunctioning to march over the last
one.
I think it was really expensive to do in the last one.
Killed a lot of rich mother fuckers.
They did it for 27 years.
Wow,
that's amazing.
Yeah,
so at first flight was in 1969 that's amazing.
They were going supersonic speeds and 69 that is a credible,
is it?
Here's where it goes.
It's on the runway right now.
It looks so bad ass too.
Apparently they're loud as fuck too,
and they take off.
Right now it's just rolling.
Built up speed.
This looks totally like a regular plain right here.
Yeah,
isn't it the nose?
It's down.
It's pointed down.
So weird.
I hope the side,
no,
it's up.
No,
it's not blowing up cause the other one blew up as it was in the air like wet
when it took off.
It's imagine if they hit that.
It looks so sick though.
Look at the shape of it.
God Damn.
I would've liked to fun and one of those Richard Branson.
I know you're out there.
Figure out a way just to make a better one.
Yeah.
See if you find one to actually take you off though.
That one was boring as fuck.
I want to see a Concorde going fast.
See Concorde go fast.
Go fast
down.
We don't see this brand very badly.
Oh Shit.
Bring that back to the beginning so everybody could see that.
Oh cheese indicator.
It takes off as it takes of it.
Hit something very badly.
Oh my God,
it's scary.
Oh,
speed indicator.
So fake.
That is
the ideal.
How can they,
when that's happened to me,
there's no way to stop at reception of a fellow marker.
Can you turn around?
There's so not mobile.
The fuck are,
we don't know.
What's a weird sort of a reenactment someone's doing like post-fight.
Yeah.
Commentary.
This one's 2 million.
That's fucked up.
So apparently a lot of rich people died on that dude.
Cause the,
the tickets were stupid expensive,
but I guess he could get to Europe and like two hours.
Wow.
That'd be weird.
I don't,
I don't mind flying when,
when,
when it like,
it's nicer that the planes that go overseas seem to be a little bit bigger
because I couldn't imagine being like on a southwest flight or not a southwest
flight,
but one those Delta flight or whatever,
where it's like super tight.
There's 12 hours.
Planes are just rude.
There's sometimes when they pack people in there,
you're like,
this is just rude.
This is like human cattle.
Yeah.
Inhumane.
Slightly inhumane.
Yeah.
But I mean that's the,
well people will be there.
They're willing to pay,
you know,
to be transported.
They're willing to be uncomfortable as long as they don't have to pay a
ridiculous amount of money.
And when you think about it that way,
then it becomes really reasonable.
Cause if you can pay a couple hundred bucks and fly across the country,
which you can,
if you get a good deal,
that's amazing.
Someone's going to take you and bring you across the whole country and like a
few hours in a day and it's going to cost you a few hundred bucks.
Just pay the man to be uncomfortable for a few hours.
Jesus Christ.
It's worth it in that sense because otherwise I'm not starting to fucking pilot
airplane business,
are you?
You're not starting to pilot airplane.
Who's gonna fly people?
Who's going to,
how are we going to get there?
We're not going to get there.
What if there was no airlines?
Who is the government going to run the airlines?
Yeah.
Good.
Fucking luck.
It will be even more fucked up.
That'd be terrible.
Bunch of government workers flying into the ocean crashing shit.
You know,
it's,
it's um,
you,
you better hope the fucking airline.
Stay in business.
Pay Your money,
be uncomfortable.
Deal with it because I don't think they're making much money.
It seems like they're hurting.
You know?
It wouldn't be a good time to start up an airplane business at all.
Right.
Air travel
is tough and flights are expensive because oil is fucking expensive.
So jet fuel's expensive.
Fuck.
And how much money it must cost to fly a plane across the ocean.
How much money is that in?
Gas must be a stupid amount of money.
I would think so.
I mean,
it's so fucking big,
but I don't know.
It's incredible that people were doing that in the 60s though.
the 60s those stupid fucks didn't have access to anything but books.
There was no phones.
If you weren't talking to anybody,
if you wear it right in front of them or you get them on a land line,
you know there was no cell phones,
then we'll just drive it around.
Calling the people no matter where you are and looking up facts on Google.
No,
but yet they were flying all over the country.
They were going all over the world.
You know,
I wonder if we're going to see like an alternative power source that's strong
and have to be able to fly planes,
but that fuel,
you know,
where you're almost like on a collider or electric car of an airplane.
You know what I mean?
If the idea is that if Tesla's inventions had ever come to fruition,
one of them being wireless electricity that could have been shooting low reality
airplane.
Yeah.
We could have developed some sort of a,
I don't understand it,
so I can't even comment on how they would do it.
I don't know how you broadcast electricity,
but the idea was that he would do it almost like you'd be able to pull it out of
the air,
like on a radio signal.
That'd be cool.
Yeah,
I guess.
Or it would be terrible because then an air flight would never work because
people would be fucking exploding in your planes because you're running into an
electrical circuit.
Like right.
When some kids shutting off his light bulb or something,
the larger started sends a short up the wire and you know up to that through the
air and the electricity in the air and Zaps your playing.
Who knows?
Obviously that's not how electricity works,
but with any sort of a breakthrough discovery,
like you know air,
electricity,
you're going to have some,
some more problems.
Right.
Especially now the Tesla is dead if they tried to using his information without
his brain.
You know how many people are capable of like brain Tesla's inventions to
fruition even today.
I know I keep on thinking about the band test lead and just makes it,
yeah,
isn't it funny?
The Band Tesla,
they,
they were kind of lame and they hijacked one of the greatest women's history.
Ego check.
Tick somebody way too cool for yourself.
Yeah.
That's kind of silly.
I guess they were fans of his,
that's why they did it,
but you know what?
I'm a fan of his too.
I don't call myself Tesla.
I know who isn't come up with your own band name,
man.
You hijack that dude's leg.
It's like almost like saying I'm Godzilla or I'm something like that.
You know the band?
Yeah.
Do your phone's going off kitty cat again
way over three hours?
No.
Would not.
Well I mean the two podcasts.
Oh if you put them together.
Yeah.
But we're not doing that are we?
I was going through part one and part two.
Okay.
Do you wanna put them together?
I was trying to,
let's get crazy bro.
Let's get crazy.
Wow.
How long was the first one?
Uh,
I think like an hour.
We do it just like they do it.
That's how like regular people do podcasts.
If you look at it like the regular podcasts,
most podcasts are an hour.
True.
We're the only ones wander on
hours and hours.
But the problem with us is sometimes we get to a spot we don't know in the
fucking end,
they know how to end.
They know at time to bring this baby around.
They know,
they know how to end.
We don't know how to end Brian.
Sometimes we're lost in a world of not ending.
Okay.
Imagine if you had your own Concorde Cardigan space cause they essentially
reached space.
They're like right at the edge of space.
Like a little higher and their it space cause I think they fly like way higher
than a regular jet.
Would you ever get on a hot air balloon new?
Not Interested.
Terrified of that.
You should be.
Fuck that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Hot Air balloons are fucked up,
man.
That's a,
that's a,
that's a tough thing to control.
No,
I don't think that's like,
I wonder how many of you will die every year and hot air balloon accidents,
but it happens sometimes the buildings catch on fire.
Oh Shit.
I think just the feeling of standing in a basket to,
I'm feeling like the wicker underneath your feet.
You know,
I'm trying to find an altitude here.
Let me see something else.
Services.
Dad doesn't say what their altitude is.
I'm trying to find out how,
how high these things went.
So,
oh here it is.
Oh my God,
you ready for this?
A regular plane is like,
what?
30,000 feet occasionally.
34,000 feet,
something like that.
Right.
Occasionally the pilot to come on and say,
we've reached 35,000 feet.
Our cruising level,
cruising altitude,
Concord's maximum cruising altitude was 60,000 feet.
Dude,
what the fuck?
Sixty thousand sixty thousand feet sub sock airliners typically cruise below
40,000 feet above 50,000 feet.
The lack of air pressure would give a time of useful consciousness in even a
conditioned athlete of no more than five to 10 seconds.
Isn't that nuts?
So apparently you can do it only because I,
that's incredible.
Is it?
Because of that,
the way the plant is built,
Concorde is out to the air.
Density is very low.
A breach of cabin integrity would result in a loss of pressure severe enough so
that plastic emergency oxygen mass installed on other passenger jets would not
be effective and pastures would quickly suffer from hypoxia despite quickly
donning the masks.
Concorde was equipped with smaller windows to reduce the rate of loss in the
event of a breach.
Wow.
A reserve air supply system to augment cabin pressure and a rapid descent
procedure to bring the aircraft to a safe altitude.
Holy Shit.
It just dives down.
Oh my God,
that was be horrifying.
Could you imagine if your shit breached and you just felt the plane point down
at earth and just,
yeah,
just straight down.
Oh my God.
God.
Wow.
So they stopped flying,
I guess in the eighties or excuse me,
that's amazing,
man.
That must've been a fun fucking thing to do.
You mean your 60,000 feet up?
I think it's dark out.
Even when it's daytime.
I think you're in space.
No,
I think it's 60,000 feet.
You're like,
you're really close to space.
You know like it doesn't,
the sky doesn't look like the blue sky that you see in a normal jet when you're
just floating above the clouds.
You know that beautiful feeling when you're in a jet,
you look out the window and it's just smooth sailing and you're above the
clouds.
Like wow,
that's so peaceful and beautiful.
I guess you're way above that shit.
You're where it becomes dark.
Right?
Ooh,
that'd be cool to see that.
that'd be awesome,
man.
It'd be awesome if we all had fighter jets to,
I mean,
you know,
I,
I just do that bit about being in an FAA 18 what does this thing,
man,
no trouble.
Oh,
hot air balloon accident.
Oh No.
The balloon check out that picture there.
You can see it was ripped open.
It fell to the ground from about 500 feet.
Oh my three people suffered only minor injuries.
Amazingly,
the paraglider had non life threatening head and spinal injuries.
That's crazy.
Snaps on.
That's not good.
Hey,
let's wrap this thing up.
Brian Reichel this weekend the Braya Improv,
we'll be doing it with a Ari Shaffir end.
Duncan Trussell and this will be the first time that Dunkin is performing with
Ari in quite a while.
I think it's going to be fascinating,
especially considering,
well,
whatever.
Anyway,
we're going to have a good time frame.
Probably most likely it's going to sell out.
I go,
yes,
yes.
I am doing a lot of new shit.
Yes.
I have a lot of the,
uh,
I'm,
I'm performing,
I'm getting ready rather tightening up my shit for April 20th cause it looks
like April 20th in Atlanta is what I'm going to shoot my next special.
I got to get going.
I've had the same material that I've been winning.
We'll looking to put down on DVD for a long time now.
It's been like I think two years since my last recording.
So I got a lot of shit.
I gotta get it out there and then start fresh,
which is terrifying.
Uh,
but we'll do it.
A lot of those start fresh shows here at the Pasadena Ice House cause it's such
an intimate environment.
It's great for coming up with new shit.
So that's my,
that's my mission right now.
I'm on a mission.
My mission is to get out this special and then come up with a whole new hour in
a couple of months.
So I'll do,
I'm going to do a lot of shows after April in May,
June,
July before.
So I'll have like a few months before the special comes out when it gets edited
and all that Shit.
And in this in the months before,
I'm going to have to come up with a whole new hour.
So that should be fascinating.
So I'll be doing a lot of shows.
Um,
and um,
that's it.
Thanks to uh,
the fleshlight for sponsoring the program.
Thanks to um,
them.
You can buy a flashlight at a discount.
If you go to Joe rogan.net.
You don't know.
Fucking deal.
Click link.
Enter in the Qa Rogan and blah,
blah,
blah.
If 15% of our plan,
we're also sponsored,
sponsored by on it on it.com.
What is on it Joe Rogan?
Weight on it is on his God's company,
my friend.
We're here for you.
What Brian?
Pay Attention.
What are you doing holding your pipe up?
Is that the photo that everybody's saying?
It's silly.
Fucking pipe.
No kill.
You know,
you can see what I'm your son.
Love.
You light it up.
You know you want to,
it's ceramic infuse.
You don't have to worry anymore.
Um,
thank you to see two.
Oh,
coconut water too.
They just sent me a bunch of fucking bad ass coconut water.
This is the most delicious.
It's from Thailand.
They're not even paying me.
Um,
thank you to [inaudible] dot com they are go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t
and a checkout,
all the different supplements,
Alpha brain,
shroom,
tech,
sport,
shroom,
tech,
immune,
uh,
new mood.
All good stuff.
All explained at [inaudible] dot com all stuff that I endorse and I use.
All right.
Tomorrow the powerful Greg Fitzsimmons will be joining us.
Greg is,
Greg is my buddy from,
uh,
literally like we started out like within the first,
within the same month of each other.
I think we're like maybe a week or two apart from each other.
So we've known each other a long time.
We've got a lot of fun,
crazy story.
She's hilarious.
He's a great dude.
And uh,
he'll be here tomorrow,
so.
Well that's it.
We've got a lot of shit coming up,
honey.
Honey,
he's got to do the podcast next week as is Sam Harris.
Holla.
Atcha boy.
So I'll see you dirty freak soon.
Thank you for tuning in.
As always.
We appreciate you very much.
And,
uh,
this podcast,
you know,
a lot of people come up to us and talk to us on Twitter and say that,
this is a huge part of your life now and it's,
it's so much fun and you grow from it and you learn things from it.
We do too,
you know.
But forcing myself to do something like this and doing it so often and exposing
myself to all these cool conversations with all these cool people,
I am benefiting just as much as you are.
And I appreciate you guys to no end.
It is the coolest thing in the world to work at a place and then have the wait
staff and everyone say,
man,
do your fans are so nice.
And I hear it all the time and I just want you guys to know that I appreciate
that more than anything.
I'm proud of that more than anything.
I think it's the coolest fucking thing in the world.
And I think if you put something out there,
it's like it's proof positive.
Be a cool person and be a nice person.
Try to at best times,
always at every turn,
tried to be as cool about something as he can.
Well,
no one's perfect.
We're all going to fuck up.
But if you go through life with that sort of a motto,
don't be a con.
Try to keep moving forward.
Get your shit together.
Be Nice to people.
How hard is that?
It's not that hard,
right?
Brian?
Have a good time.
This shit is temporary.
It's not gonna last.
You got to wake the fuck up and realize that time to enjoy this fucking thing
for the mad lunacy of what it really is.
The Times right now,
enjoy this fucking thing.
Enjoy the shit out of it.
Cut Out those people in your life that you're not enjoying negative people.
Vampires.
Cut them out.
Cut.
Cut Out all the bullshit that's holding you down.
Scam and scheme and plot away to get out of your job.
Do it all.
Don't get me wrong.
Find out a way to do what you really want to do.
You can.
This fucking is getting way too.
Um,
now I'm like,
no,
I'm a motivational speaker.
I've gotten Anthony Robbins on everybody.
Look,
I'm just loving y'all and I'm just a,
I'm a little emotional because of jet lag and,
uh,
that's it.
CND wearing sloppy.
That's,
it's a good,
good example.
All right,
well,
see you guys tomorrow.
Thank you very much.